I don't want to be a first adopter those
[ __ ] thing's gonna fall apart
boom joke do you guys n-word live oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] did you really go out and
buy one of those iPhones last night did
you order no red band called me and he
goes are you gonna get because I asked
him a few weeks ago everybody I want to
get the yacht you know I don't know
anything about computers so I call red
man he's my computer guy so I went to
get the iPad the big one the 99 and I
asked lady because my phone's [ __ ] up
already she's just wait for the 8th so I
called red van about a month ago he goes
wait and last night he called out of the
blue goes you gotta get online at
midnight and I did it like an [ __ ]
I just forgot my code I got through I
got through the second click second
course click boom order I ordered the
silver black Bam Bam Bam and then at the
end I get the [ __ ] cold for I iTunes
a novel I woke my wife up in the middle
of the [ __ ] I did she really did time to
get the [ __ ] I did
so are you [ __ ] crazy waking me up at
12:15 some stupid [ __ ] phone there's
gonna be lines around the block at those
Apple stores it's it's crazy
it's like those sneaker lines when you
see those people they're out to buy
sneakers for the supreme lines now
Supremes got a whole thing I mean kid
they wait in line for three or four days
now and over what almost weekly alright
I'll show you this [ __ ] you're probably
gonna freak out when I show you what
they're waiting please do it shovels
bricks with just the word supreme
written on it shovels and bricks
t-shirts are the main thing what is
supreme exactly it's a brand it's a
streetwear brand and people wait in line
for bricks I'll show you
that's [ __ ] kids today this is what
happens when kids don't go outside they
don't play
they don't play sports and they stay at
home they just play video games Nancy
Reagan's fault with it just say no these
kids smoke dope they see life for what
it is yo Sam I'm gonna wait in line for
an hour for a [ __ ] break look at that
supreme crowbar they sell a crowbar so
the crowbar we just have like the name
supreme on it okay who's using that no
one uses it it's like
that it's real you have to look into the
brand a little bit to understand it but
it's sort of part of the joke almost
there making parody of the craziness of
it all by just throwing their brand name
on stuff and people are buying into it
go back to the page so supremely we're
in top 10 non wearable supreme products
Jesus Christ they have fire
extinguishers yeah new trucks but some
of the clothes are cool diff nunchucks
it's just depend you gotta be really
into it and some people are really into
it like I said they wait in line for
days well I don't know we're making
money off of it cuz they can buy it for
40 or 50 bucks and flip it for 200 well
I don't understand like why is everybody
buying this limited limited quantity
business what's awesome but what is the
big deal about supreme I cut you have to
look into the history up there's some
YouTube videos you can look up
you sound like Eddie Bravo gotta look
into it it's really hard to explain and
I like can't even it'd take me a half an
hour to get into it I don't want to
hijack the show supreme right now so
well I just never I wasn't aware of this
I thought it was just like a t-shirt
it's where it started you so Josh Martin
wears him he spends a lot of money he's
a fool
well he wears those goddamn Yeezys that
you were to I don't spend much money on
I get in for retail then buy him
otherwise yeah Josh Martin is like into
every trendy thing everything that comes
out he's like way ahead of the curve
supreme Jesus Christ Joey I don't give a
[ __ ] I didn't know about this do you buy
a hammer
it's a supreme on it the fact they sell
nunchucks is hilarious supreme nunchucks
did we wait on line we were not for
anything like last night was watching
something the real story about the
Godfather and they showed when they
released the Godfather at New York and
there were lines yeah the movies yeah
I'm sure waited in line you'll see Star
Wars but not three [ __ ] days can't
doubt the night before not for a hammer
what did they camp out for back to him
they kept out for something really I
feel like the first I ever saw it was
iPhones when the first iPhones were out
I remember going to the mall and going
what in the [ __ ] am I seeing and there
was a giant lion outside the Apple store
and this was like when one of the first
iPhones
was coming out and I was like quiet
waiting for a phone you don't have a
phone already like this it's the only
way to get the phone I was it was all so
confusing but it was a thing where
people would wait in mine and then they
would look at each other and I remember
when I remember when they were waiting
in line for Harry Potter when Harry
Potter was coming out and people would
drive him by earlier yell and now
Dumbledore dies at the end
another they're yelling out all these
different spoilers all I typed in was
waiting in line for in Google and the
only things that come up are iPhone
supreme and iPhone 8 or gasps yeah
that's right the seventies with the flag
yeah
red green a yellow flag what was that
there was like in the mid 70s there was
a gas shortage so Green meant that you
got gas if you had an odd-numbered like
if your license plate under the nod
yellow was even and then red was were
shut down [ __ ] oh yeah that's you
remember that they had to fly in 73 to
75 maybe something like I don't know the
exact dates then they had a weird line
studio 54 had a huge line but you got
picked Studio 54 3 or 54 was on fire you
showed up and you didn't guarantee to
get in you got picked right the way they
do now in Hollywood like they pick hot
chicks right so they pick hot chicks
what was the thing we're talking about
one night they won't let a guy in
without a check something yes I'm for me
going to go out in clubs and yeah they
never would let guys in without chicks
so if you walk into a club with three
guys they don't want you they want the
chicks in there first
yeah well the glass thing one is a
sausagefest look at all those dudes try
to get in look at Stewart look at this
that was inside but outside the deal are
the people well that could be it no
that's outside that sound what a zoo I
just try to get in just to try to get it
what was the big deal about studio 54
you could snort coke dance get your dick
sucked and get your shoe shines all at
the same place and be home by 6:00
it was a vet you know I mean everybody
was dead like this is that Andy Warhol
it's Andy Warhol but was the girl look
at us she's got a be a bottle in her
mouth you know champagne on champagne
yeah
[ __ ] Black Sabbath this 154 look at
Mick Jagger's wife dancing with any
Warhol looking liza minnelli behind them
Wow so it's just like the place to be it
was the place to be you could go crazy
strange he strange times huh but here's
the beauty of it they have a station but
serious and it's called Studio 54 you
can just put it on on Sunday nights they
do a podcast and what they do is they
interview people that actually used to
go there or work there and I never tell
you something John they had a dentist on
about a year ago and his wife that it
was crazy listening to this interview
about what their life was they were
professional dentist making money in New
York they stayed out till 5:00 6:00
every night but went home took the kids
to school went back home took a nap -
one got up went to the dental office
work till 5:00 went home took another
that fed the kids and at nine o'clock
they'd [ __ ] him bring the kids
downstairs to their moms and they do it
all over again five nights a week over
and over and then the lady was saying
not till he is Leila Liza Minnelli
thought I was a publicist
she goes she didn't know I was a dentist
they just saw you in there it was draw
trust funders you know that's all the
people who could do that type of [ __ ] do
blow till all hours of the night you
could put it out they even had an
interview about when Bob home went to
studio 54 five hope I hope walk through
the studio that know what the [ __ ] he
was gonna wear he was gonna walk into he
went out to the middle of the floor and
started dancing and these chicks got
together started tying Bob Hope up just
tying them around like an Indian he's
just dinner like laughing Bob Hope style
don't you think it's just a [ __ ] joke
they just left him there and they just
tie them up and left them there tons of
stories out there like that you know
like just but then they moved on but you
got picked to go in there how did it
move on like imagine how weird it must
have been when it finally the door shut
and that was it
the people were it was their whole life
for years people move on you know clubs
get hot different clubs I went that one
time and they
a three maybe eighty four it was done my
friend who's already done yeah every
time it was just a bunch as I was trying
to be cool Wow and I found the holla
bill I was out of money with a bag of
blow no cash not a dime in my pocket
can I look down there for no more there
was a holla bill and that's how I got
saved that's how I got home wow that was
it that's my studio 54 story it is weird
those clothes the nightclub scene the
nightclub scenes a very strange scene
now one club gets hot and then it dies
off and the people that are in that
business like try to figure out what
makes something hot and what doesn't you
got to rename places and redo them and
reopening and grand reopening and get
people to show up like I remember
hearing that they were paying Paris
Hilton like [ __ ] piles of money to just
show up a club that's it
the Kardashians and any of those people
they pay a shitload of money you're
there they take pictures and the club
gets hot now after buddies start taking
partners it yeah
shut because you know what's on the way
down I'm so against you so after a year
some guy comes and I love your place oh
yeah I'll take care of ya and that's how
you get out of it or you do a lot of
people didn't they just like the place
on fire stuff and scratch a little
Jewish lightning the play starts to
scratch you know I knew the guy that
owned the gay clubs in Houston like in
the 70s and he was telling me one time
he was you know once we got our you side
of him you let him on fire like the
insurance and then open up another club
that's it Jewish lightning Jesus Christ
it's a weird scene you know I mean
people that just look forward to just
going out and just drinking and dancing
and snorting coke every night just
looking for like experience just
something different and wild it takes
him out of their everyday grind just do
it over and over and over and over
different like when I was growing up it
was club area was big and the rooftop
you paid like 24 bucks to go in at 11
o'clock and you drank all night till
7:00 in the morning 24 bucks all you
could drink
it's [ __ ] booze I mean you're not
drinking kavadi and [ __ ] right when
you're doing blow you just burner that
[ __ ] anyway you come out they give you
sunglasses and that's it if you went in
after three was it was like 20 something
after 11 and then like 17 bucks or you
could drink after three so seven in the
[ __ ] morning and people were packed
that's what New York was about back then
it was just people staying out those
seven six New York is what a four am
glass call once last call in New York
I've no idea
Florida I think it's even later than New
York Florida Florida it closes for one
hour five o'clock in the news cafe right
well [ __ ] and we're having a good
time at five o'clock they'll come over
to you and say hey do me a favor by five
o'clock the bars are the closed so you
can't ought to be until 6:00 so we just
all the twenty five beers and you wait
to the ball pizza six and now you're
[ __ ] ready to drink again I got this
for one hour one hour
this was back you know twenty years ago
15 years ago I'm gonna grow but a weird
rule one out remember that place we used
to go to right down the street from that
improv yeah the Lou's cafe yeah that's a
great place right place great breakfast
great [ __ ] ball the club went
downhill hard though yeah that Club that
place well the whole Coconut Grove area
became the only thing that's still open
to the dueling pianos the pizza joint
that more the dueling piano places -
yeah it's in that little mall there with
the movie theater they always have those
right next to em probs like they have
one in Addison - right Addison they have
one up next to Jon Lovitz up in
Universal they do yeah they used to if
there's a [ __ ] we pulling up there
Miami has a 24-hour really drinking now
oh just Miami just in a Miami
entertainment district it says oh well
that makes sense it's 4:00 a.m. Broward
County and Key West yeah a little
different everywhere else in or later
West Palm is where we always worked
we either worked in Miami at the improv
which is Coconut Grove or we did West
Palm after Joel opened up that new place
the big giant Sal I saw some great place
yeah then the new place though is like a
theater it's like 600 seats it's [ __ ]
huge I mean that's a huge club it's a
great place that I and even for a lot of
there was a great club inside the casino
which they read the
/ oh yeah that shut down oh dude shut
down till next year yeah we have no
action now there no kidding that was a
fun little clutch a fun little Club
because that's a good size that one
there in the Hard Rock's good so that's
a good size yeah the last time I was
there there was a couple next to me that
was [ __ ] in the bedroom next to me and
like animals I mean like [ __ ] animals
I mean like porno film animals like like
I was lying in bed and I heard the any
was in the afternoon I was trying to
take a nap but these people were I was
like Jesus Christ that [ __ ] Florida
oxycotin dick one of those pain relief
centers you take two of those things you
get your hammer with a dick 10 times and
she won't go dead bas Rutten total story
the other day that I read online I'm one
of martial arts websites about his
addictions that's a great article Oh
scary scary [ __ ] scary [ __ ] well he was
talking about trying to get off of it
and how difficult it was and you're
talking about a guy with like an iron
will you know in bas Rutten imagine the
average person who just has a hard time
getting out of bed in the morning
doesn't have a lot of discipline and
they get hooked like that's it that's it
you're gone it's [ __ ] amazing that
stuff's legal did you watch 60 minutes
three weeks ago no that was the whole
look that was the [ __ ]
[ __ ] it wasn't just about the
open opioid epidemic it Oh the DEA stop
prosecuting the word came from you know
it's just a nightmare they're [ __ ]
terrible things listen those things are
terrible yeah there was a whole article
recently about the company that that
sells most of the opioids and the family
that's behind that company and how many
billions of dollars that they've made
off the opioid crisis opioid opioid or
bid how we say opioid I always say it
wrong once that should grips you that's
synthetic heroin that's what that right
isn't yeah potentially yeah it's uh
it's a bad grip like I said I took a
sixteenth one night in my living room
and I had to lay down and that was my
that's my whole resume with ox and cons
and I'm a [ __ ] mule
I can eat 2,000 milligrams of THC and
live 1/16 and one of those pills I
popped it was just a little piece
nothing
my blood pressure drops so [ __ ] much
I just laid down went to sleep and I
knew my pill correct I'm doing that and
never even let it start really never
even let it start can you believe
brother in two weeks is gonna be ten
years since I've done that white powder
we need to think about that Wow I really
think about I still remember being at
Cobbs with you that January and like
going it's been two months I don't know
if I could really do this [ __ ] like I
don't know if I control this feeling and
I controlled it so you like when you
quit what was like the first week like
hell hell first two weeks were hell did
you think about going back just like I
can't do this or did you know that you
had to make a change I had to make a
change
I knew that my spine was starting to
hurt I knew this is buying this time
yeah I was trying to get jolt in this by
4:00 in the morning you know after you
do coke oh right at the tip over here
people done coke get like Parkinson's
you think that's related well a lot of
lot of old-timers that did a lot of coke
in the 70s and then they wound up like
some serious neuromuscular Bob salute
that [ __ ] shops gee a central nervous
system there was times I did cocaine
that was like electric it was like when
you put that thing in your hands or you
get electrocuted you could feel the
electric in your body and next day like
that like in your brain like you can
actually see this is the
neurotransmitters the [ __ ] on fire
you could feel that you know I could
tell when I would go on stage after
doing two or three nights a blow that
week I had no control I really had no
control over my material I no control
over my delivery that's what I want to
tell you like you're just the way you
keep running off yeah
I can't grip it you can't sell the joke
the facial doesn't connect with the hand
movement Oh or the breathing so like I
knew that that was always going to be a
danger in the future now you know I take
all that uh for like a year I drank
those what's your buddy's name that
makes the neurosurgeon no shakes the
football player they [ __ ] the guy up
Romanowski I took all his stuff for like
a year just to did you yeah the orange
drink is for neuro one that stuff okay
yeah it felt good to feel a lot better I
didn't give you brain some nutrition
control yeah but ten years I mean that
that I had to do a benefit in Hoboken
and I gotten high like that whole summer
I tried to get off coke I was doing the
heroin I was trying to get off the coke
and [ __ ] and then that September I ran
out of heroin so I was doing like maybe
once a week and the whole thing went
down in Maryland I knew I had to stop
and then I had this thing in Hoboken I
went whole thing went down Marilyn
Martinez yeah when she died he was dying
I would I went back east that week and
she was dying I don't know what happened
it was like you know what I was trying
to get coke on Friday night I couldn't
get it and I just took it for what it
was I was trying to get coconuts
Saturday I couldn't get it so [ __ ] it I
took the plane back son there couldn't
get it here something happened I
couldn't get it and then that Monday I
had a meeting to do a movie and at the
end of the of the meeting the guy said
listen man we know about your drug
problems so before you say yes we want
you to think about this because you
can't miss a day on this movie you
cannot be late if you're late the whole
movie can't shoot because it was a cast
hmm we all shot in one room wasn't they
a meeting so I thought about it I'll do
it
and that was the roughest [ __ ] month
ever cuz I was just going home and
before 8 o'clock would start I would
just go to bed because 8 o'clock was my
cocaine time that's when my body would
start to ache that's when I couldn't
even you could be telling me the most
important thing in your life and I'd be
watching you but I couldn't hear mmm all
my mind was focusing on was getting that
blow at 8 o'clock Wow and then I would
figure out how to get the 60 bucks you
know
I'm gonna go to the ATM machine I would
shoot over the rock and roll' rouse
there's an ATM machine in front of rock
and roll Ralph's right there yeah and I
would take sixty bucks out that I would
run every red light to get to the ATM
machine
but I didn't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
from there we just make the u-turn go to
my dealers house go home and leave the
coke there and now he's ready for the
night I was in peace just knowing that
the coke was at the house I didn't have
to do it you know I've never been
physically addicted to something in a
way where I had a hard time kicking it
but I've had some psychological
addictions for sure and I think that one
of the things that's that I've gotten
out of this month of no the sober
October thing that Tom Burton Ari and I
are doing is that a lot of it is
psychological law because just knowing
that we can't smoke pot or can't drink
all month
you start thinking about oh we're at the
home stretch November 1st around the
corner like I don't really feel like I
need to get high it's not like I need a
drink tomorrow but it's knowing that I
can't do it for the month where it hangs
over your head so that's what's even
more impressive that you could kick it
because it's not just the fact that you
you have like a physical problem but you
also have this psychological problem
like the psychological part of it is
like it's it's a pattern that you're
comfortable with you got used to that
pattern of 8 o'clock you're looking for
the coke you go into it and then you're
off it's like you're off even though
you're you're in chaos your life's in
disarray and you're in the grips of
addiction you're comfortable with that
feeling you've been there before and
you're but for whatever reason when
people get used to [ __ ] up and they
go why do I keep [ __ ] up one of the
reasons you keep [ __ ] up because
you're used to [ __ ] you and it's not an
uncomfortable feeling in the sense that
it's it's even you know it might suck
but you know it's the devil you know you
know that was nice I didn't want to do
it I still did it in this family yeah I
didn't want to do it like I didn't need
to do it like I feel I just want to do
it but it was just something to do like
it was just something that don't
Wow it was just something to do but you
know what I tell people all the time is
you want to have to quit it just doesn't
happen like I quit at 44 I'm no [ __ ]
genius but it took me two years like it
was a two-year struggle like a personal
little struggle like when it was with
you that you were free cuz you didn't go
to a no Narcotics Anonymous
I went to one meeting and they ain't
meeting him I want in Hollywood which
everything is good until you go to an
Hollywood because in Hollywood you act
at you you add to dramatic and the actor
image to it you know if you go to a
meeting in Jersey they're in there
smoking camel Reds [ __ ] talking from
the heart you gonna lay a meeting in
Hollywood you got people with AAA
tattoos on their arm I'll give each
other you know it's a [ __ ] Jamboree
this is happy to be in a yeah it's a new
clan that they're in and then what
happens is after about two months in
this area for some reason I've noticed
cuz I have a lot of friends are they a
they somebody approaches you this is
high you know what's going on you're
like I'm struggling really why have you
seen dr. Bob like dr. Bob gosh I'm just
making this crap they're like dr. Bob oh
my god to tell about dr. Bob tell Joe
about doc dr. Bob was changing my wife
so basically you'll see dr. Bob
he gives you [ __ ] referendum
whatever description what you have you
know oh you're you're this now they
start shooting at her all the others
Shanaya so you're really that sober
you're really not so but you see now
after I got clean I discovered I had a
problem I discovered I was bipolar or
Johnny goo BOTS or this or that or this
now that medication they give you you
know on top of the old opiate epidemic
how bad a [ __ ] animal
adderall is so [ __ ] that means animal we
have someone every month that's on
adderall when they're doing the podcast
it's obvious yes they can't shut the
[ __ ] up they talking about fast pace
they're really excited they've gotta
look just a little bit too much energy
there's something about them that you
just know and you just like you could
tell like you're like whoa whoa slow
down sometimes I've all offer him a
drink I mean I've had people on the
podcast where I tried to figure out what
the [ __ ] was
went on and then later on in the podcast
they told me they did adderall and I was
like okay alright now I get it
alright now I know where all this
tension it's crazy chicken we knew they
used to take two outer walls and [ __ ]
the chicken West palm or something used
to drink oh dude everybody does do you
know how many people do it though I'm
getting stunned all my like the families
that I know like with my kids or friends
with their their kids and I get to know
these people
[ __ ] these all these like successful
suburban people are doing adderall all
the time that's how they get through
work that's how they become successful
they're always hustling throw he's
getting things done and these
[ __ ] they always want the
newest [ __ ] they want the newest watch
oh is that the newest you bowl is that
the newest this is that the newest dad
oh he's got the Mercedes AMG oh look
he's got this and she's did she bought a
house in the Oaks oh you know look at
this and she's got a VAT and look at
that purse yeah where'd you get that
I heard that such a Hermes oh you can't
get those all they're doing is like
chasing after these things so they can
go places and other people will look at
this new thing that they have it's very
strange it's like there's one thing like
if you know someone who gly collects a
certain thing like they're you know so
we're really into [ __ ] whatever it is
old samurai swords or something like
that they love the history of it that's
not what these people are doing they're
buying things so they could bring places
and other people would go woo so they
get a feeling like a feeling of I guess
a successful feeling you know they get a
feeling from other people recognizing
that they have the latest thing like oh
where'd you get that jacket oh look at
that purse oh look at that wow look at
that chain how many carats is that ring
let me see your ring girlfriend let me
see your ring amazing it's so cute those
shoes are so cute oh my god so cute and
they're just like weird [ __ ] just
filled up people what weirdo speed it up
people that elect chasing after the next
object it's a fairy it's a very string
and they don't talk about [ __ ] I get
together these people you know because
we'll have dinners together or our
families will get together the kids a
play will
a party together and you know a good 20%
of these people do not talk about [ __ ]
all they talk about is objects they talk
about this object and that object and
how much this is worth and how much Real
Estate's going for here and that's the
whole focus of conversation it's like an
anti-human conversation because they're
not talking about anything human they're
not talking about you know with the
community what they love about life and
their experiences as a parent and none
of that matter
well I don't don't even pay attention
they're kids they they go and drink and
leave the kids outside and the kids are
just [ __ ] hitting other kids with
sticks and [ __ ] and going nutty and then
when they come out no my kids a good kid
he doesn't do that and then go back
inside and drink more and it's like
crazy it's really interesting to see
it's like the things that fuels success
in a lot of people are a lot of these
folks it's like this this need for
material possessions and then pills
this is what's going on you didn't come
you and I didn't come from the best home
conditions available to us I'm not
insulting you
no you're right the same you had to
deliver papers and your mother had a
work and Lou and the whole [ __ ] thing
do you ever sit there sometimes on one
of these [ __ ] parties with these
people who have everything yeah
everything we didn't have and you're
like my parents worth 20 times better
than these [ __ ] people as a parent
yeah I come sitting there every day now
I'm apparently little pools and
gymnastics tonight I got a [ __ ]
recital I mean I have to do this is
right who the [ __ ] a part of my I am but
I see these people that do this [ __ ] and
I'm like my mother was a [ __ ] bookie
my mother owned the bar and she was a
drunk and she was a way better parent
than these [ __ ] guys guess she was
there I think what we're talking about
with this pill thing there's a lot of
people that are on antidepressants
there's a lot of people that are on
adderall there's a lot of people are on
xanax there's a lot of people that are a
lot of weird disassociative
and these disassociative pills you see
it in how they interact with their
children they just they just zone
out there not there even if you're like
stressed out about your kid you're
interacting with your kid at least the
kid knows you're communicating with them
the kids probably not happy that you're
stressed out but at least you're there
when you're zoned out on pills and
staring at the [ __ ] clouds it's just
it's just not it's not a good way for
human beings to interact with each other
well you're hopped up on some weird [ __ ]
and I think I mean I don't know what the
actual numbers are but are in the
communities that I associate with I
would say a good solid half of these
[ __ ] people are pilled up a good
solid half they're either pilled up on
xanax what's really hilarious is I've
talked to some of these people and
they're like I don't know how you smoke
pot every day I'm like [ __ ] you take a
xanax every morning every morning you
take a xanax I know a lady who takes his
antics every time she gets in her car
she's like just too much traffic
OOP Pops's annex for traffic the Pappas
annex to go to sleep the Pappas annex
cuz they have to fly oh I have to fly
need a xanax unedible
yeah for those four hour flights I just
can't sit there no more well those
intervals make you think about the
universe I mean people say it's a
different thing though when I have mercy
in the morning I don't [ __ ] get high
I don't get high like I have her in the
morning before school and I Drive I try
to cuz I gotta walk into school for a
week like it
they already warned me one time they're
warned you smell like I went there pick
her up and one of the teachers came
along she was a little that's Friday you
were kick it bunch of last Friday so I
can't embarrass my daughter so I track
that was it that was it once they said
it that's funny
then the answer you know I take my
chances I get high go to the gym this
class was swimming or the ballet or
whatever the [ __ ] we have to do and
that's you know I'm out with my friends
are doing the podcast doing comedy so
but I don't all I have I don't have beer
in my house generally you don't really
drink you've never got along
I don't want alcohol in my house neither
have a child don't know what alcohol in
my house well I'll tell you what if
there's one thing that I could kick that
you know like this sober October [ __ ]
like if I could if I had to choose like
for the rest of my life
no booze are no pot I would say no booze
and a heartbeat yeah but I like a cold
Heineken eyes attempt Oh
cold cold valium was [ __ ] delicious
but I get something out of pot I get
like sensitivity I get community
I get compassion I get introspective
thinking I start examining myself more I
become more humble I get something out
of it I get like real benefits out of
pot like a lot of the Bennets of
benefits that some people would call
paranoia or you know that people they
freak out because you know they think
the walls are closing and I love that
that's yeah it's good for love that I
live in that world I [ __ ] love it
I love somebody telling me I'm a loser
get it together
you have some dick today get how the
[ __ ] you watch TV I think you're not
proud of I'm very proud of Bert
Kreischer for kicking the booze this
month Barry and listen this will help he
stays off of it well or at least what do
you think you put these guys in rehab
this month practical rehab is a rehab
it's just to let you know where you
stand
60 days if you're not doing a certain
something makes you know where you stand
and sometimes you go you know what
you're rolling I'm not gonna smoke Bob
but I'm gonna have my drink twice a week
that's cool too you know Bert has a
problem flying you know he likes to [ __ ]
and get twisted you know but Bert's what
you call a social drinker yeah some
[ __ ] Florida you know they wake up
they have the little [ __ ] cocktail
when I was gonna take a nap they'd go to
the beach you and I don't know that life
I've never lived that life of drinking
all day and then taking a nap Bert's a
real soldier you know but it's not
[ __ ] around Bert's not an amateur
show Bert's the real deal I saw him
running a couple days so I'm running
through my car and when he was running
at me and [ __ ] with his little thing I
just took the car and you started going
at him and he's like and I looked at me
like coz he's in my neighborhood so I
saw I watched him a lot I went over
there I tried to get him hi he wouldn't
fault he was gonna bring drug tests the
other day when we were I was on number
13 I think and they were on number 14
and re was gonna stop at CVS and pick up
those marijuana tests
they just didn't have the time you know
I'm very proud of birth and all this is
gonna let you do look at even you with
the re4 now it's gonna let you know that
you didn't have to smile when I went to
prison the hardest thing about prison
wasn't going to prison you know it was
how am I gonna live without my marijuana
feeling how am I gonna [ __ ] sleep I
wasn't worried about nothing else in
prison except marijuana I never get any
in prison no you could 50 bucks with two
joints that were brown weed I wasn't
doing that
but after the first week you learned
about yourself you learned that you
could go with that which is one of the
strongest things that can happen to
somebody it's like when you're when
you're in love with that girl and you
can't you're destroying your life yeah
good job and you're drinking you act
like an [ __ ] and then she goes away
now why for two weeks after ten days you
like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
what do you think people get divorced
when they're like when their wives leave
for ten days yeah
their wife goes back to see the mother
and you're sitting there going what am i
doing a woman I don't care so I'm much
happy in this house I can put her in the
back somewhere and not see you know
that's what happens when you realize you
could do without that's one of the
biggest things in your world that could
happen to you yeah have no idea well you
don't think you could do without in the
beginning because you think maybe you
could possibly get her back if you can
get her back everything's gonna good you
got this bad feeling because she's
thinking about leave and you're like oh
no she's gonna leave maybe I could talk
her back in maybe I fab eye or something
maybe I could do something maybe change
my ways and I'll bring her back and I'll
bring her back and everything's gonna be
fine but everything is fine if she
leaves you just meet somebody else
that's it just come on relax a second I
gave up sodas I never thought I could
give up a coke you [ __ ] crazy you
like those Xevious do you like those
things
what stevia Jamie coke in himself what
serious zvo it says it's like they're
sodas with it a flavor with stevia
people think I'm doing a [ __ ]
commercial for these things they don't
they haven't paid me a nickel I'm not
taking any of their money to their soda
but they're flavored with stevia and you
don't know sugar uncle they have like
raspberry
they have root beers they have like ones
it's like a 7up
they have one that's like grapefruit
soda they have a bunch of different ones
man they're [ __ ] great I love them
I'm soaked them water them I don't give
what is great too
I don't give a [ __ ] anymore doc get out
of these stupid things though oh they do
have a cold one right yeah give him that
cream soda that one's the [ __ ]
that right there and I Cola Diet Coke
sucks what a month ago I was on a plane
and I was a little you know loopy and I
just let me try a coke got a coke I
couldn't even finish the little [ __ ]
8 ounce glass it's too sweet yeah that's
another day accidentally a late-night
drive-through starvin coming home from
the store and I got a burger and I asked
for a diet coke and they gave me a
regular coke I went oh this is so good
it was so delicious yeah what'd you once
a month I'm gonna give myself a coke or
actual coca-cola once a month what you
and then get the Mexican ones with the
room
yeah the mandelic taco joint yeah cat
rice go to cactus I'm where you guys
usually go right there they [ __ ] good
but once you realize like you know we
got a boy I grew up in Jersey I got a
sandwich I got a bag of chips right it's
not the sandwich that kills you it's a
bag of chips if I have a turkey with
Swiss and avocado I'm not gonna [ __ ]
die it's the [ __ ] 22 ounce bag of
chips all those things once you give
them up like I had to give them up of
wait watches they were tough potatoes
were breakfast that was tough
that was tough put those up for me when
switching over to like in and out and
getting a double-double with the lettuce
with lettuce wrapping on the top of it
that's called the protein style cheese
though that's the way to go
cuz you still enjoy the [ __ ] out of it
tastes amazing but you're not getting
all that bread it's still fantastic and
it's it really not bad for you I mean
it's just ground beef cheese lettuce
it's not I mean there's nothing terrible
for you there I just think that you know
when you spend too much time eating
shitty food your body is gonna just feel
terrible but if you can just limit that
shitty food to occasionally then you'll
appreciate enjoy just for this I have a
meatball sub like you know yeah every
night every now and then you know what
Cabarete --is you ever go to cabaret
yeah [ __ ] you place so good I get a
sausage and pepper sub there every now
and
was real Italian bread I mean it's a
[ __ ] thick I would have crossed
Italian bread Li you clamp it down it's
hard on the outside but soft on the
inside you bite into that you feel that
real juicy Italian sausage in that
marinara sauce I got two weeks two weeks
two weeks I got I go home in two weeks
oh you're going home in two weeks I save
everything for when I go home I don't
[ __ ] around
I don't eat Chinese food out here no
more I don't know what about pizza do
you [ __ ] around why are you saying I got
a place for my house I got to taste them
if I walk in there with you
you'll drive down really yeah it's that
good don't take the pie to go no you
gotta eat it that you need a crazy slice
you got to get my slices that are
rotating mm-hmm you bring that pie home
it's like a [ __ ] falafel but yeah
bring it home and put it in your oven
all over again
that's the secret like yeah but putting
your oven all over you know when no one
does right here white pizza no because
no was Catholic there was a [ __ ]
there's a pizza place in White Plains
New York down the street from executive
billiards I think it was Nicky's Nicky's
pizzeria and they had this [ __ ] white
cheese slice this white pizza sliced
with and it had like you could see the
olive oil and butter in the pizza and
the garlic and you would bite into it
you'd be like holy Christ and the crust
of the pizza underneath is just like
they're just the right amount of cooked
whether it was like a little bit of just
a slight burn to the crust and you're
biting into it and you're just feeling
the cheese in the dough and all the
sauces and the Oh some [ __ ] during
Lent when you grow up back then you go
to your friend's house on Friday and
they get like mussels and red sauce at
Nicky's that's the place and white
[ __ ] pizza we'd walk to that place
right from executive billiards right
down the street
[ __ ] phenomenal place so our good
street fight there once and that's what
it is the other thing that bothers me
the most
you know the slices you know the [ __ ]
slices yeah here's a move a slice is a
thing of a move okay what's a slice of a
move a slice of a move is you me
you're on the [ __ ] move when I come
in to see Joe's pizza and I go let me
have two cheese to go and you give me to
me other thing and I fold them up I eat
one there and take one I want to go go
get a slice in the Hollywood someone
what happens they take it they write a
receipt if they hang it up and some
other guy comes takes the slice out puts
it in you have to wait for ten minutes
then they come with a number and they
give you the [ __ ] slice listen do it
all one shot use your dirty hands they
ain't gonna kill me then I'm gonna kill
we have them give a [ __ ] of you scratch
jazz throw the [ __ ] the heat from the
oven I'll kill the germs I'm saying just
draw the slicing everything's a process
a slice that's the whole corporate yeah
it's a move it's everything like that
[ __ ] I know what you mean
everything has become corporate and
these places that you're never gonna get
that old small restaurant feel from a
place like this that you'll get from a
place like Nicky's pizzeria you know you
know in the the flavors are different
like we've talked about this before I
don't know what it is and I've heard
people say it's the water but whatever
it is the place down the block from
Gotham
that's what I can do God fool I'll show
you this slice right here I even took a
picture of they got a sausage Stromboli
in there that'll make you [ __ ] fall
out you understand I just took a binder
but I won't need a whole Stromboli
that's a heart attack at night that's a
delicious meal what a Stromboli that's a
heart attack
that's a you know it's got a good
Stromboli and real Vegas Vegas all right
there's a place of Vegas that you got a
Stromboli and they put to have couches
in the back well they must have left
over again if we could take a nap yes I
have leftover guineas from when the mob
ran Vegas right you used to go to a
place that Eppley used to take you to
the Italian pool place that you said
that place went under unfortunately did
it yeah that place was fantastic that
was some of the best Italian food in
Vegas and you would get it at a pool
hall it was so weird
look how beautiful that slices look at
the [ __ ] sauces from bowling my nice
guy that's like a florist yeah this is a
heart a kind of beautiful flowers this
is dos hermanos Cuban rest
they've been serving Cuban steak
sandwich this is 1960 that's all they do
that's all they do
use the steak sandwiches we're in a
place West New York New Jersey that's
the place we took pictures of people
that's beauty that's Mona Lisa in my
world lobster tails the date the one
from Jersey with the cream all those
Italian [ __ ] cookies right just take
picture so I could show people here what
they're missing like this is what this
doing this yoga thing where I did 9/10
yoga classes in a row whatever it was I
think it was 10 you you I'm hungry all
the time
cuz I'm doing 90 minutes of yoga every
day every single day not a day off for
nine days or whatever it was let's say
it was nine but even it was nine I took
a day off before that I did two days in
a row so it's like over the last couple
of days or last couple of weeks it was
11 classes you know mostly in a row and
just always hungry just constantly
hungry like your body's just craving it
and so I've been eating all sorts of
[ __ ] that I never allowed myself to eat
like late night like grabbing a burger
and they're like I had Wendy's Burger
last night coming home from the store
not good for you but felt good but you
burned right through that I do work a
lot I burn right through there still not
the smartest thing to do
just not I feel so much better when I
don't do that when I just limit myself
to that like once a week I feel so much
better but I just I don't I don't
necessarily think it's good to do
anything nine days in a row I just feel
like your body is just like I've got a
weird hamstring pull that's going on
right now and
just everything feels like a little worn
out you didn't run this month I didn't
run but one one day the first week of
the month I'd lifted weights a couple
times here and there but almost the
entire month it's been yoga so far went
to a jujitsu eight you know when I want
the runner do I have to call in the
weights and I do this little [ __ ]
kettlebell crawl little ski like my
backyard just to get that hip thing
going so I laid the set Oberto gavazzi
stuff no I decide like somebody told me
to crawl and I started crawling like
you're in the army like in backyard they
started crawling I [ __ ] around your
yard
yeah just crawl around oh yourself on
your hips this [ __ ] do all this [ __ ] on
your elbows
I like it so I've been doing that well
when the gyms installed the gyms gonna
be installed here in two weeks
you got to come by we'll do a workout no
I don't want you to teach me the the
Darce and all that stuff
I'll half guard and all that stuff okay
great sure that's great that you got
this place this is a [ __ ] big place
this is a crazy place right
but it's this place we're gonna do all
kinds of stuff here we're gonna have it
set up where people could follow along
the workouts I'm gonna get someone to
like guide us through a workout and like
I'll say hey everybody grab a 35-pound
kettlebell we're gonna go through this
like that Keith Weber guy that I've had
on before
Keith Weber I'll get him to come up here
and teach that extreme kettlebell
extreme cardio workout it's [ __ ]
phenomenal workout that you can do with
135 pound kettlebell and you'll pick up
a 35-pound cannibal you like [ __ ]
workout am I gonna get with this little
boat weight that does it five minutes
and you'll be dying guaranteed 100% even
if you're in good shape it's hard if
you're not used to that workout is
[ __ ] hard and by the time the thing's
over my legs are on fire you're 35
pounds 35 pound what kind of [ __ ] are
you doing like Oh clean presses over and
over again hot potatoes back and forth
renegade rows you're doing like one
push-up with one hand on the kettlebell
switch to the other side push up with
the other one doing them pass it in
between your legs and you're going one
after the other one after the other
windmills over and over clean press
snatches and you're doing these in
succession over and over again switch to
this side switch to the other side 10 on
this side 10 on that side and you know
and it's we're talking about like a
45-minute workout we have them you can
you could buy them all over the places
but we have a man on it he's got three
of them out three different workouts
they're [ __ ] crazy DVDs I mean this
kick this guy's he's a trainer up in
Canada it's just in tremendous shape but
the videos are so good because it's one
of the few videos where a lot of these
kettlebell workout videos like people
were teaching you proper form which is
all important you know it's real
important to learn proper form learn
where to peep to keep the weight
balanced keep your weight in your heels
and keep your feet flat on the ground
all the different things that they want
you to stress about various individual
movements but Keith Webber's like you
better know all that [ __ ] because we're
just gonna take you through a radical
workout like ready here we go
boom and he does he's doing it all with
you he's doing it on the beach it's also
any crazy [ __ ] yeah the guy's good too
from our bure though he's good - he's
got a nice little workout no more oh
yeah that's kettle jitsu guys guys yes
5:00 5:30 a.m. i watch it online
5:30 a.m. he's going [ __ ] a stack of
people in there and they go right to
jiu-jitsu it's 6:30 how great will it be
the show up I get up at 3:00 a.m. yeah
that's what I'd be ready at 5:30 for
that type of [ __ ] have coffee
I gotta have coffee smoke pot have a
protein shake right a little bit just so
not to think I can get change fired yeah
I can't have a heart attack I just can't
get up and go over that the good thing
about doing a workout like that before
to g2 is that you'll approach jiu-jitsu
like light is this him kettle jitsu yeah
he's got a good program like he's doing
hip escapes he's calling it snake moves
while he's holding on to a kettlebell at
the same time that's phenomenal for your
core these rocking-chair get ups you
know what I really like man I do these
sit-ups with kettlebells where I put a
255 pound kettlebells or 50 pound
kettlebells over my feet I put my feet
through the handles and then I put two
in my hands and I lay back on my back I
press them up and then I sit up with
them pressed up and I do my sit ups that
way and it just makes your core your
your ab muscles just so goddamn strong
yep 225 you give me
I don't tie my feet and what I do is I
go back and
like go this way hmm I do like a [ __ ]
Burpee okay yeah the legs going now
that's great too well from my back but I
do that in the end that's one stand back
up all the way oh no no I just move back
go back in the back at least
it's like I get me to a table mm-hmm
yeah we get into a table I wanted to
strengthen all that [ __ ] and it helped
me strengthen my back doing oh that's
those are great workouts because they're
not it's not like a glamorous thing
where it pumps you up it gives you big
dog makes you look Jack but it's just
great for your body your circulation I
told the bag in there oh yeah so to warm
up I hope it up with the bag very
lightly probabilities close distance
then spread out punches bum bum
just get everything moving push-up
stretch once you do 20 minutes that then
I start doing my stretches to really get
the muscle warm then I go back and I
start throwing kicks that kills uncle
Joey once I start throwing the kiks kiks
kiks system I crawl then I do my cleans
I do all the Oberto gavazzi stuff with a
15 pounder now instead of using the
kettlebells for swings they win the
middle of my back I used to fifteen I
turned my arms and I go up boom catch
them Oh
raising the club's yeah they're [ __ ]
great do you uh do you ever do Turkish
get-ups I do up to a degree yeah just so
I take the the ten me whatever it is
boom boom boom and then I do like a
table instead of getting okay well
that's good it's all right yeah no no I
do it that I like all that stuff any of
that stuff like when you're lying down
on your back and you're pressing
something up and even just getting up to
your knee it's all just about like
strengthening your core you know do you
do anything for your legs like do you do
like bodyweight squats for your legs
squats the goblets you'll have to do
with your with weight Evoque I do it I
do I start with nothing and then I work
myself up to a thirty five goblet ah and
then I do you know what man my knees are
kind of yeah you've always had some knee
issues the left one the right one now is
a little funky so I I stop with the
swings
I love cleans with kettlebells that's my
[ __ ] so I like the combination clean
and then squat all those are great and
then I do another clean squat and I do
five on each side does anybody run you
through a program or do you just come up
with this on your own whoever I worked
with oh thank god
and they just decide to do whatever you
want Alberto is there my wife got me a
bag for Christmas I got to Calibos from
you do you want to join us if we do some
sort of a challenge some next-level
challenge some next thing you want to
join in I don't know I don't know I'm
just thinking I just see this is one of
the things that I've realized from this
doing the 15 yoga classes I would
[ __ ] never do nine yoga classes in a
row like that I would never do nine days
in a row unless I said I was gonna do it
but once you say you're gonna do
something and you do it it's not that
hard you just you just wind up doing it
you know what you have to do it like my
alarm goes off at 7:00 I'm out the door
I get to the class I do the [ __ ]
90-minute class and then I'm done and
then I go do my [ __ ] and then I know the
next day when I'm get doesn't matter if
I get home from the store at one o'clock
in the morning my alarms going off at
7:00 I'm getting up I'm having a cup of
coffee I go there fasted I just have
coffee you work out early
yeah see I don't like getting nothing
I'm good about 11 of 12 I have eleven
o'clock podcast a lot of times like
today's 11 o'clock podcast so I'm up you
know I already got a 90-minute workout
in come here you know stop it like Whole
Foods or something like that get a
coconut milk eat something I get the
coconut milk now and mix it with the
acai vanilla Jesus Christ is delicious
ice cubes yeah I never liked the ice I
even though but they ran out the
chocolate yeah it's not to sell
something I'm like beggars can't be
choosey good googly moogly it's very
good it's very good you know then the
good thing about that hemp horse protein
is it's very little sugar that's why I
use the water scoop a couple grams of
sugar that's called nut milk yeah no I
like it I like that one I don't mind
doing a challenge here's the problem Joe
Robbie here's the problem what happens
that a lot of people don't realize I
know the jujitsu right let's say I go to
our boroughs right I boroughs has some
[ __ ] killers
so I'll do the break the guard past the
guard right couple those and then we
start rolling
well a guy like me an older guy starts
rolling and that for the second 5-minute
roll he's opened up he's all I'm open
like I called though Jim I told you
what's my problem bro how come I'm not
breathing goes you know you guys know we
throw out the gun and I gotta work I'm
out in the back of 45 minutes before cuz
they can't breathe either it's just just
go with it so if I do more than those
two roles it's a law of diminishing
returns
I really can't walk the next day it's
it's hard well you got to build up to it
you gotta build up to it so that's what
I'm that's why I like this other guy in
a way because you work mm-hmm one day
you drill you know one day you work I
could do uh wait [ __ ] like I like wait
[ __ ] I was thinking of joining your
buddy's gym for a really good workout
Terry Norris mm-hmm
Terry if that's the one in Studio City
Terry Norris attack clayman there's
other terry clay bond is the guy used to
train with who's in Hollywood know this
former boxer yeah he's amazing he's in
hell he's in Burbank is he really
[ __ ] yet he has a Groupon for like 30
visits for a tune-up so he's like
teaching people on a box yeah Terry
Norris was bad [ __ ] little
corner store it's up the quarter from
it's up the corner from a famous
bodybuilding gym
oh yeah it's right there up the corner
from there's a [ __ ] great restaurant
of their breakfast restaurant and he's
right there how is he like talking and
everything's York because they had a
thing on him on television he's having
some issues I think his was wife is
there yes somebody else there but he was
bad guys yeah she said that it's
interesting because like he's got all
these issues but then once he starts
hitting the back right he do he comes
back and he looks like Terry Norris of
old yes talking and struggling you know
he just I remember seeing him once I was
at a boxing match I was actually with
Damai rera and Terry Norris stood there
talking to people and this is before he
died retired like officially and he was
talking to somebody and you could hear
the slur and I was like whoa like I had
no idea no idea was this bad
you know all those guys those guys that
are in Wars like your you'll you will
run into them one day and you will say
it all you'll see the war in their voice
you'll see it the slurring and the the
weird tics and the movements and you're
like oh you're looking at a frazzled
person there you know the shattered did
Jamie show you the hit from last night
the way you watch the hit from football
last night Oh what happened
somebody get smashed or yeah but you
know what's crazy
this was football ten years ago now
they're [ __ ] done like did I hit it
hard anymore no you can't well how'd
this guy get hit so watch this yeah it's
it yet the main issue on it is like it's
a quarterback played they do this thing
where they uh I guess they're called
kits giving up their body they slide
with their legs first they're not
supposed to get hit like in almost any
way or maybe you're supposed to tap them
just to like let him know they're down
so this guy gives up his legs and if I
don't find the video to trying to that
while I'm talking but he gets hit really
really hard and then when you see it in
slow-mo it kind of makes a little worse
cuz the dude led with his arm don't come
right now helmet oh he goes like this
Joe oh you see you're like damn I'm
surprised and throw my like I didn't
watch the game when I got up this
morning was all over the place it laid
hit lady I wonder if one day they're
gonna be able to figure as a sit right
here yeah here he goes running boom
oh Jesus why is that guy mad cuz it's a
late hit they got furious at him let me
see it again
show from other angles and you'll see
protecting the quarterback is a big deal
that's - got it I hit him 47 Kiki Alonso
I thinks his name Kiko that's the guy
who got hit at Joe Flacco for the rape
all right here we go
he's running he's running this is the
angle it's rougher well he was already
coming like how is he gonna stop it
stuff that's the part about that so far
feet-first let's see that's good to be
like you're supposed to stop it's like
kicking a fighter when their arms are
down kind of thing it's a rough time
like I know that changed the rule
recently but sort of the same kind of
things
he hit that dude even though the dude
was already down the guy went down on
his own accord he him sliding feet first
means he's not supposed to be hitting
him like that he should know better it's
what that was why everyone was mad
that's why his coaches yelling so he
just took a cheap shot at them yeah
exactly and he hit him really hard knock
them right out of the game so what
happened to that guy 47 he gets a fine
right yeah that dude you get suspended
for three or four games he got his bell
rung yeah that's a [ __ ] up thing right
in college football they're taking them
they're taking him out of the game right
away he would have been probably thrown
directly out of the game potentially
missed more and maybe half the next game
and so they give a penalty to the other
team
yeah so an NFL right now it's just a
penalty how many of these football
referees are on the take
how many these guys get busted like
that's a big thing about NBA players I
was reading this whole thing about how
little NBA players make and how they're
constantly watching all these NBA or not
NBA players NBA referees me and now
they're watching all these players pull
up in bentleys and Rolls Royces and
shining with diamonds and gold and
jewelry and that these guys just start
taking bribes and that there's at one
point in time where there's just a
shitload of referees in the NFL and the
NBA that are just on the take really yep
and they they'll get bribed by bookies
they'll get bribed by you know people
that are big-time gamblers and you got
to think if this guy's only making I
mean how much does a referee make system
here between anywhere between 150 and
500 thousand oh yeah well that's a good
living but if someone comes to you if
you make 150 and someone comes to me
goes Joey I just want you to make this
game a little bit more easy for the
Dolphins here's a hundred here's how
much they make per game per year and
some players there make that per game
now pull up bribery in NBA referees or
corruption and NBA referees it's been a
bunch of guys that have been busted
right I don't know about a bunch I think
it's really just the one guy
just one he tried to call out a bunch of
other people but he didn't do it by name
who dharna he hit him Donnie yeah I
talked to him that guy did you he's not
my podcast yeah no [ __ ] what'd he say
good god it's just a [ __ ] listen you
fall in that trap man right they have so
many scams like he was telling me they
got like the first class tickets [ __ ]
mm-hmm you know where they give you a
first-class ticket the travel to the
games just so just a little bit of this
a little bit of that you know well
there's always a lot of that with boxing
as well no in college basketball just oh
this is like huge
this is tremendous coaches and some
different programs and I think it was
adidas might have been so they were
playing families we're getting paid
through the shoe companies to direct
players to certain schools oh and then
they were getting signed by those
companies when they made it to the NBA
and in some cases I think Rick Pitino
who's the coach for Louisville is taking
something like 98 percent or 95 percent
of the money that was due to the school
from adidas he was just keeping at all
what yeah what no yeah I don't know
legal is a weird word on that I mean
it's in the contract and it was like
cash and so is paying him basically yes
if you go back to the movie blue chips
which came out a long time ago it's all
being it was like fictional then but
that's been going on for the last 20 so
why would they pay him like what are
they whether they get the D just wants
to like what does adidas get out of he's
bringing in the most popular players
that are going to be like most popular
recruits from high school and AAU and so
that maybe he could bring them to adidas
and then adidas you have them all over
the final for the NCAA tournament
they're gonna be on Saturday basketball
they're getting advertised just like NBA
players but they're not getting the
money they're getting using their names
there's lights you know they're all over
SportsCenter so they essentially would
adidas would pay him to be an influencer
100% yeah wow that's weird that's a
weird role so he would be the father
figure or the coach figure to these
young men they look up to him he's a
mentor in some ways and he weasels them
into the adidas fold and they would
they're also what they want that they
want to wear a Dita's cloth stuff yeah
they want that the cool jerseys there
make Ohio State right now the team I'm
pay attention to for football have some
awesome crazy jerseys that nobody's ever
gonna
get that like the LeBron James brand of
Nike is giving them that are gonna be
showcased all over TV Saturday Wow
I was reading about Under Armour is
banking on Steph Curry's new Under
Armour shoe how much they were saying
that Steph Curry who's like one of the
best players in the league apparently
you know that more than I do I don't
know [ __ ] about basketball they were
saying that his new Under Armour shoe
there they're putting a lot of money
into this idea that his shoe is going to
rebound the stock so people are making
recommendations to buy Under Armour
stock now so that when the shoe comes
out everybody gets crazy and buys his
shoe and then Under Armour will bounce
back you know the problem is once once
something has a stink about it it's kind
of it you know is that bad looking in my
opinion and from knowing what I know
about sneakers that's not the shoe
that's gonna bring them back what's
wrong with that shoe unless a bunch of
kids are into it which I don't know that
they would be it's all it's more about
marketing uh-huh so you have to get a
whole bunch of kids into buying that and
then there's got to be a couple
influencers in the I like MBA video game
world and like the YouTube blogging
world that are gonna have to make this
seem cool to them what influence what is
insane is this a Steph Curry on an SC 30
his number Oh looks like an SC doesn't
it I mean I guess I wouldn't wear these
shoes at all it's so much [ __ ] money
in the sneaker business you wouldn't
wear those when you wear those
goofy-looking Yeezys i also like I
wouldn't wear these casually I'm not
playing basketball give me a tissue so
if some people might be wearing these
for basketball they're a lot of kids
still play in basketball if they can get
a team into buying them and you get 15
pairs so that's two a team you're
talking about two totally different
worlds right you're talking about
there's people that buy shoes to wear to
play in casual or and then there's
people that wide buy shoes just to hang
out in correct yeah whether they're
doing them they're buying athletic shoes
for handle purposes right and these the
marketing of it is a real weird place
because Jordans are where it all started
Michael Jordan got everybody wearing
shoes you know yeah and Jordans people
don't play
basketball and Jordans correct or do I
don't know they don't look cool when you
wear it you're wearing those [ __ ]
cool Jordans yeah oh so if you wear
Jordans playing basketball like this
guy's so [ __ ] crazy he's playing
basketball in Jordan or even the a like
that he's playing basketball in $1000
retro Jordan we know cost $1,000 them do
no wait yes really
I mean brand new retail they're costing
about a hundred to two hundred dollars
nine hundred twenty bucks retail but the
rarity of them especially depending on
the year they came out if they came out
five years ago they some of them cost a
thousand bucks 2,000 bucks out the same
[ __ ] with jeez you know every really
whatever I get like a cheap key take out
those shoulder roll what do you call
those show your roll yeah people wait on
money for those yeah limit they made a
Michael Jordan they made a guy that
don't do jujitsu they put a guy out of
Michael Jordan key that they sold in
Chicago I know a guy that buys all those
keys like they do the same thing like
lucky limited time only midnight nickel
and they have hundreds of geese they do
not work really because the shoulder
rolls to show you rolls I don't know
exactly what they came back no I like
dots asuras dr. sybers good stuff yeah
those are great like that that goes
where you know where the dots hussar is
nice it's it's real durable too because
the hemp is just so much more durable
than cotton it's just those things I
mean keys are pretty goddamn durable as
it is it needs it takes a long time for
one starts to break unless you have a
single weave you know when those thin
lines are great I love doing all the
mats pretty much yeah I love food James
I got the white one the black one that
you could pull them I'm a gorilla in
that day but they're like this why do I
wouldn't this is why I knew I wouldn't
do well in hot yoga first of all I'm
Anna Akana
you could tell all right even here
Millie I don't respond well to when I
first started you JIT that was the
biggest problem I had that I didn't know
anything about G's right so I wouldn't
bother judogi I hit that heat that heat
level one
way up that took me to a different place
yeah those double weave G's like those
things those are very heavy but some
people like that they like the double
weave they like the feeling of like
security of having that very thick cloth
around them some people like that golden
weave I like the single weave this only
the summer before yeah yeah I wanted to
feel light I don't want a [ __ ] G you
know what look at the size of me if I
put again it's 20 pounds also for me I
have about staff a couple times so I
always put a rash guard on anyway even
if I wear gear I just don't just people
get scratched from fingernails all the
time and I also carry those defense so
the white wear spray mm-hmm the soap I
got the soap in the shower yeah but I'm
on my [ __ ] feet when do you drink
kombucha yes that's so good getting
probiotics do you ever have kimchi every
kimchi that's what it smells [ __ ]
disgusting I love that stuff even though
Asian that says I'm Asian I'm the
[ __ ] thing I buy a [ __ ] jar of
that [ __ ] like a 32 ounce jar and I'll
eat most of the German kimchi like a
book it's Babich it's pickled cabbage
it's fermented cabbage from Korea and
your farts smell worse than tennis
they'll clean the paint off your [ __ ]
car now I like the camp introduced I
just can't deal with other [ __ ] damn all
that stuff is good for you I don't do
the Greek yogurt either now I like to
regularly yell the Greek yogurt tastes
like ass [ __ ] that I tried the vanilla
plain like all the other ones you know
well over the last few months I've been
shying away from from Dairy
I've been I'll eat a little cheese every
now and then because I like cheese but
I've been trying to like eliminate dairy
from my diet a little bit just to see
because I've heard from several people
that they've eliminated dairy and
they've had good reactions their body
they fed like less inflammation it makes
them feel better on that [ __ ] that's it
on that report I'm lactose intolerant
yeah yeah yeah I took a milkshake once a
month to you know a climber
I'll drink a milkshake I'll make a
banana shake at home with someone yeah I
like my shakes then so I think that's
what I'm gonna do for November I'm
trying to figure out what I'm gonna do
for November but I think for November
I'm gonna go the entire month without
eating any [ __ ] a hundred percent
the entire month just all straight
healthy food no added sugar
no no nothin no sodas no crap I'm just
gonna see what that feels like
I'm just we got it we're gonna come up
with some new challenge because after
this month doing this I feel like this
was a very beneficial month for me
beneficial in that first of all my back
has never felt better like doing yoga
all these times like it makes your back
feel bulletproof like you just feel like
my posture and everything like
everything is just that feels so sturdy
because yoga especially B crumbs like
that 90 minute hot yoga shits so much of
it is about your back and your core and
like supporting your spine and I think
you know sitting down a lot doing
podcasts even though these chairs are
phenomenal these capisco ergo depo
chairs these things are phenomenal they
keep you you know sitting in the right
posture and their support you well it's
not real good to sit down all the time
like that and a lot of times your back
is like compressed and if you don't have
good structure and if you don't have
good strength around the spine like good
muscle strength around the spine you're
gonna develop all sorts of weird
problems and you know weird weird issues
with your back but I think I've learned
a lot this month about like what what
kind of exercises you need to do to keep
your back strong you know like this yoga
[ __ ] like doing it as many times as we
did it this month I mean I'm not gonna
do it this many times but I'm definitely
gonna do it two times a week from now on
definitely you know and if you mix it
with the weights a little running you
can go don't ya you're good to go
that's that you don't need much in the
Olympics right trying to maintain you
just trying to maintain keep your
[ __ ] whatever going that's all it's
not a lot have you ever done the
cryotherapy
cryotherapy the cold [ __ ] yeah I worked
myself up but it's right down the hall
of miles have you know I just always
forget to go down
phenomenal I think I had a lot of
problems you know I wrote I wrote the
[ __ ] whatever the first four chapters
for the book for your book yeah that's
why I did all this in September which
all right what are you writing a book
about what got me into comedy why I got
into comedy just the biography yeah hey
dizzy and I finally started August 1st I
got the iPod whatever the iPad you write
it on an iPad [ __ ] yeah and I write it
my hire the kid he had it's everything
for me
oh yeah so I had to have four chapters
done I got to taste them so you have a
book deal yeah I wanted to write it
properly I wanted to write I didn't want
that every time I had somebody else
write it Joey Diaz is like a Floyd story
they used to sing the last guy good
story Floyd thorium's whatever the [ __ ]
those peoples have no [ __ ] Dorian
story who's Floyd I have no [ __ ] idea
you know these people you know you know
writing has gone like when you read
Silence of the Lambs right it's just
plain writing but sometimes you read
these books with the writers go a little
too far with their [ __ ] it's just
too much it's like you were saying you
ever go to people's houses and they talk
and then you say [ __ ] for 20 minutes
they like it's like by Studio City where
I live
go to that coffee shop anytime the time
you know what they were saying in there
well the day after the Vegas shooter the
Vegas shooter was Sunday night do you
know what these idiots were saying in
their Monday but that this had to do
with women's rights and the abortions
and and they just talked these new
breathing Gentiles they just talk that's
all they do is talk with big words to
impress you but they don't say [ __ ] they
don't say [ __ ] three or four big words
to let you know they're smart and then
then say nothing and there's a lot of
repeating narratives oh yeah every time
the show the new show I'm gonna do I'm
buying one of those little tape
recorders and I'm putting them under
these six [ __ ] morons every day yeah
at night I'm gonna do a show about what
they discussed because this is 60% of
America what these [ __ ] people are
talking about this is the idiots the
[ __ ] that comes out of their mouths is
amazing and you sit there and go
no wonder [ __ ] Isis wants to shoot
listen to these [ __ ] dummies listen
to what's coming out of their mouths
women's rights that's a total well what
was their argument they were saying that
the guy bow they all got everybody the
argument is everybody trying to be small
and everybody it's just six people
trying out with each other it's like
when you go to those [ __ ] dinner
parties you talk about and by the time
they serve the salad you want to put a
gun in your [ __ ] why am I even
[ __ ] here with these people I could
have stopped at Burger King and had a
better [ __ ] time that's why I don't
go to those dinner parties because
there's eight people to and once
politics comes up you lose me Joe Rogan
I don't want to hear about it no more
you lose me you lose me these new
political people talking nonsense you
lose me move forward either impeach him
get a new woman or shut the [ __ ] up I
can't you put the news on any more butts
definitely he didn't send the check he
called her a hey what the [ __ ] man just
tell gives a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
there's got to be something more there's
gotta be a seal stuck on a beach
somewhere in this [ __ ] country
something more important than this [ __ ]
every [ __ ] day so the politics is
over my world religion you know I don't
want to be yeah that's supposed to talk
about politics or religion at those
[ __ ] things but this new breed of
Gentile they just talk for the sense of
talking to see who's the smartest person
in the room but at the end of the day
they're all a bunch of dumb [ __ ] anyway
it was definitely a lot of people
talking and just impress other people
yeah that's it and there's a lot of
people saying a bunch of things that
they've read on blogs or read on
websites everybody wants to have an
intelligent conversation and everybody
witty get the [ __ ] out of here you know
get the [ __ ] leave me the [ __ ] alone
mm what would you rather them talk about
life something that makes sense
something simple that you're not trying
to impress me talk to me about your kids
what don't you think there's a lot more
that we Hollywood because people are
trying I think one of the things about
Hollywood is that people are always
trying out for auditions they're always
going in on our dish
and they're always they always have to
be picked and chosen and they're always
trying to position themselves like
someone that you would want to hire and
so they manufacture these these
attitudes based on what they think they
lift their finger they hold it up they
find out which way the winds blowing and
that's the way they go and they start to
sort of construct their personality
based on what they think with all the
casting agents all of them a hundred
percent of them are liberal they're all
liberal everyone's liberal everyone
across the board is a Democrat or the
radical ones are Bernie Sanders
supporters and everyone has like very
clear left-wing views whether you like
it or not not not a judgment on it but
these people that go in for auditions
and actors which is most of what you're
running into either actors or
screenwriters or someone who's trying to
do something in Hollywood they all want
people to know that they're on the right
team and they all want to say all the
things that they think need to be said
where you saw a lot of the hypocrites
was in the first few days of this Harvey
watch please
and you know what man at the end of the
week they're all [ __ ] disgust us cuz
they all [ __ ] knew about it oh they
all knew about it for years and then
they all want to raise their [ __ ]
happy you know what bro when Harvey was
given the movies nobody was complaining
yeah was complain playing it from a girl
she was saying that uh Harvey Weinstein
gave them all careers like wow that's a
crazy argument
the one tattoo of the chicks thank them
in the Oscars yep now you're gonna make
you listen to leave me the [ __ ] alone
the ones that really need to smack at
them off of the guys that came out and
said I got molested once I I got my dick
got touched on a party one time we live
for that [ __ ] we live for somebody to
touch our [ __ ] dick
we're not gonna go to therapy with us
ain't nothin somebody grabs your dick
you just [ __ ] smile and whatever
everybody needs a break from time to
time I'm saying you never let a gay guy
suck your dick what I excusing their
mouth no it's a party game I don't know
I don't know but I had a friend one time
that he'd let anybody suckers anybody
anybody anybody wanted to suck his dick
it sucked his yum-yum stick really one
day he was telling me about [ __ ]
getting his dick sucked by a gay guy
with ice cubes in his mouth I nearly
[ __ ] died he just let think I do it
yeah he the [ __ ] was the conversation he
was telling me how his mouth was cold
and all this [ __ ] and that was [ __ ]
dying I couldn't believe it
the guy was sucking his dick listen I
don't want to know about that I would
want to know but you wanted to know
about the guy get his dick sucked by a
dude with ice cubes in his mouth I mean
why not what he told me is watching it
first of all well he told me the story I
was young I had never heard that story
before I was like one time but if it was
so good why not keep going you know it's
tough to find somebody will suck your
dick with ice cubes in the muff unless
you give me the small fifty I think once
you put it out there you put that flag
up think um that was the funniest thing
with that crazy [ __ ] from Superman cuz
she popped up like eight days later
Harvey took his dick out one time that
Tom put that back in your pants and
crazy chick from Superman with ya what's
that chick that's crazy oh the one that
was hiding in the bushes when they found
her she had no teeth that one what the
hell's her name what's her name
but the Superman will Christopher Reeve
right no the other one was it Superman
Oh Christopher II the early Superman
right yeah was the one with Dean Cain
who was the crazy being Cain who was the
one in that Kenner Margot Kidder is
crazy right yeah sure this was the other
one that the other one but you're
talking about the one who was in
Superman with Dean Cain the TV show yeah
makes it was a really pretty girls named
Terry
she got talked into Mike but she was on
the TV show she was she was in Desperate
Housewives - right yeah no wasn't her I
had an ex-girlfriend of mine get so mad
when I was talking about how pretty she
was missing Superman actress found
frightened in the bushes yeah that was a
96 Margot Kidder yeah she went crazy 47
year old Canadian born actress best
known you know what that's the thing
once you hit like late 40s and you one
of those actresses and they stopped
calling you are already crazy and the
pressure builds up she'd cut off her own
hair with a razor blade an attempt to
alter her appearance a Glendale police
sergeant Rick young said
oh boy
to all of you Medical Center for a
72-hour psychiatric evaluation they
could have spared 71 hours and 50
minutes by just bringing her to me that
[ __ ] is crazy know what happened there
with Corey Feldman though I don't know
he arrests all that thing yeah I just I
made a joke if people get mad we they
got mad but it wasn't them getting mad
was me getting mad at myself what was
the joke uh he was wearing a really
small jacket I'm always doing this
performance at like a minor-league
baseball game and he was doing like this
Michael Jackson thing and that the
jacket was so small I go is that a
jacket he was wearing when he was
getting diddled when he was a little kid
it was just trying to make Greg laughs I
just I said something that I was and
then afterwards when I saw it especially
out of context it was very disappointed
in myself
he was he was ten million the [ __ ] if
I saw that he's out of his mind I think
I don't think he first of all he never
said that Michael Jackson did anything
to him he was he said Michael Jackson
didn't but he said that there's a lot of
pedophilia in Hollywood he wants to make
some sort of a movie on it which I'm
sure there's a lot of pedophilia in
Hollywood but like this idea that people
are trying to kill him he was saying
people trying to run him over and sound
what isn't that what he's saying
yeah I watched the video fool have a
hard had seconds and I felt bad yeah if
they wanted to kill him he'd be dead
yeah drugs tried to hit him that's not
real see this is like weird paranoia
[ __ ] let me tell you something if they
want to kill you you're dead and it's
not gonna be trucks trying to run you
over it's gonna be a guy out of nowhere
shoots you in the head and gets in his
car and no one's gonna know who he is
and no one's gonna catch him because
they're gonna hire a professional like
this idea that someone's gonna like miss
him with a car and then they're chasing
and running him down I find that very I
mean it's possible but I find it very
hard to believe I always think that like
if someone is a very powerful man like
like I don't know if the Clintons ever
whacked anybody but if they did they
walk those [ __ ] people like that one
guy that was the big the big conspiracy
theory about the
guy who released all the stuff to
WikiLeaks the Denham DNC guy Seth rich
yeah they killed that [ __ ]
whoever did it whether he was killed
because some random person decided to
shoot him in the back in the middle of
the night and not steal his watch or his
phone or his wallet whether it's that or
whether it's what Julian Assange from
WikiLeaks said is that this consequences
to leaking information to WikiLeaks
because that's what they were saying and
people were saying look this is another
one that Clinton body-count people and
there's you know giant conspiracy
theories about how many people the
Clintons have had killed I don't know if
that's true or not I have zero
information but I do know when people
want you dead you're dead you're dead
when they're real people like that that
are real killers and evil [ __ ] there's
a lot of people that've been killed like
Putin if Putin wants you dead you get
shot on TV in front of everybody and
nothing happens no one goes to jail no
one gets caught you're just dead that's
the type of people we're talking about
so this you know I just I have a hard
time believing that like someone's
getting like barely missed by a car
that's like some movie [ __ ] like they
were coming after me but I Drive to the
bushes of the last minute and now I'm
hiding in a motel somewhere and I can't
tell you where but if you give me ten
million dollars want to make a movie you
know what I feel bad for Corey from when
you see that when you see that
performance I mean everybody's a nice
kid and stuff but you can see how he was
just [ __ ] made a mockery like they
just beat him up dog grew up on TV and
they beat him up grow up in the movies
you you know you don't have a childhood
who the [ __ ] do you know who I named one
that made it through that meat grinder
of growing up famous that's not
completely [ __ ] crazy name one name
one look Miley Cyrus might have got out
of it better than any of them she's like
her new albums are really good she's
music she's great bro told them you've
seen those ones that she's up on the
hill in Tennessee with a little band and
they're singing outside in the mountains
she's summer of Jolene
yeah Jolene Jolene that hopefully no no
she's great I have always liked it she
got a little weekend yeah we play we
played some of it before yeah she
[ __ ] once she started talking about
no reef of [ __ ] I used to see it the
weed store all the time
with a brother at the weed store she was
smoking more than anybody now she quit
whatever 20
yeah she's 23 she's talking [ __ ] she's a
kid
she's [ __ ] got more money than God I
wanted to show I would watch the show on
the road Hannah Montana please my kids
like that [ __ ] show I love her on
that show she's tremendous yeah play
some of that give me some of that what
are in blood well that's good it's not
like we paid a shitload of money for it
[Laughter]
have you seen have you seen John wick -
yeah right we just watched that like
it's entertainment it's not gonna want
an Academy Award but now they loved it
but if you think about how many hit men
like that scene in the train station
that chick with the viola and also she
puts that thing away she takes the
sandwich or out did you see it in that
you give Machado yeah I watched it twice
I haven't seen he you know he gives this
part - he plays a cab driver so the
other that could think about is to fight
he had the garage with the cab drivers
when he was [ __ ] shooting at him and
all that [ __ ] how nasty [ __ ] Mighty
Mouse is armbar how about John Wick's on
boy ahead with his foot that's the
[ __ ] Mighty Mouse Rehberg that
[ __ ] armbar that he does is be Borg
great Borg great Berg hey you know what
I realize in your your fault your
computer is uh having problems with the
internet mine is not my computers I have
one I just switched routers routers it's
there it's the Wi-Fi router Oh you Ron
so that was on Wi-Fi and then you went
to Ethernet is that what you did is
switching back and forth but I'm around
oh I see
so who trains them for reals Joe Rogan
well he's obviously got a Machado jacket
on so they must have been doing some but
I tell you what like all the jujitsu
moves and the judo was a hundred percent
legit like there was no like shenanigans
like you see him throw somebody around
he don't believe it
like even his front kick
diligent front kick look he's doing real
[ __ ] you know what else he did that was
real he did a lot look at he's doing all
this [ __ ] strength and conditioning
footwork moving he's doing all these
roles another thing that he did that was
super real was he did a lot of tactical
firearms drills like a lot of you know
close-range handgun [ __ ] whereas you
know shooting that uh steel targets that
pop up and hiding behind things and
turning corners and shooting at targets
real quick like legitimately looks like
he knows what he's doing don't have you
better chat with him I've known him
fondle never met him tremendous I bet he
said eats breakfast at dukes why is this
in Hollywood yeah I'm the way I just go
what's up dawg when you go what's
happened man have a great day yeah this
is the [ __ ] that he did yeah he's real
there's a whole video of him going
through these tactical courses and
you're like whoa that's legit like he's
putting in the time man t30 [ __ ]
looks great for 53 feet 3 that's crazy
he looks great looks [ __ ] great
that's a good Kimora yeah see like he's
rolling what does he him that's not a
black belt busy
no he's white belt yeah white belt with
a black what they do is they have a
facility you see this facility where
they just redid this in Culver City the
Machado's - no that's he again the
company the 187 whatever the name of
that company is his company production
company so they have everything they're
like most companies you go to have a
couch and screams this [ __ ] no this is
what I don't think this is the place
they have like a real [ __ ] place
where they do all stunts and that was
that John over there yeah jean-jacques
John Jacques enjoy yeah there's heekin
John stare all the Machado's but all
this stuff that he's doing is like super
legit there's he again I mean he's he's
really he really wanted to learn jujitsu
like he learned real jujitsu as opposed
to just making up some fake moves and
[ __ ]
no his arm ball with the bullet at the
end is [ __ ] beautiful movies they're
fun ridiculous sort of cartoonish
violent movies it's really good times
let me go say yeah those itself yeah
[ __ ] crazy
well who's
girl to that is that sort of androgynous
lesbian character who's in a lot of
stuff orange is the new black is that
who she is she's very pretty she's got
short hair
she's the hit woman in the movie oh yeah
she plays a deaf girl a deaf girl yeah
doesn't you play the Deaf girl and what
John wick - no she's the hit person and
she's the the killer that wanted to kill
him
the [ __ ] her name did now she kills
herself is that the chick that kills
herself
no she doesn't kill herself her just
show me the [ __ ] I am dB no that's
not it
what's the who who's in the Ruby Ruby
Rose that one yeah that chick you know
she's real famous lesbian type character
oh yeah she plays a dead that's it she's
a death in the movie
I don't remember she's like this and
she's telling him that she want a
nightcap this [ __ ] but she's always
speaking yeah she speaks sign language
in the movie oh yeah yeah how did I
forget that you stopped smoking weed
that sober I'm just watching people get
shot I'm not paying attention to the
actual plot it's just a fun stupid no I
love a boat that's the wheel I love him
I like all his [ __ ] movies man
there's just some people who watch them
movies don't need to think yeah well
he's got some classics I mean think
about the John wick series he's in the
matrix I mean this dude has been in some
[ __ ] classics and Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure that's right you go
back to that I mean imagine that that
guy started with like a really silly
comedy and then went from that to be a
giant action hero and somehow or another
still looks good at 53 what's that movie
he made with the bank robbers that they
[ __ ] my big [ __ ] movie pay moving
Patrick Swayze [ __ ] good movie - yeah
I wanna know what piano Reeves does to
reduce stress because he looks [ __ ]
fantastic look at him look he's never in
trouble you never hear from him of the
bar or drinking or drinking wine
while hanging out with nobody or abuse
he don't do dick he grows his beard out
he walks around looking dirty when you
see him in the daytime my god like what
is he doing he looks so good he's just a
regular guy there's no trouble I know
but a like I wonder like what he eats
because someone told me that he actually
smoked cigarettes like he's that he's
not like particularly like disciplined
about his health
that's incredible 94 to 2014 how is that
even possible imagine if you ran into
one of his ex-girlfriend's he looks
exactly the same
she looks like an old hag she's like
what the [ __ ] I mean that's 20 years of
difference and he looks the same
well he looks like [ __ ] in the 2013 no
2012 2013 was a rough turn one that fell
off the road well that's when he met he
everything changed like doing jiu-jitsu
and his life [ __ ] shake he's starting
to podcast he called me up to go down
there yeah on what um some network then
they should maybe know learn English
first or no yeah it doesn't matter they
love him anyway they love is that him
smoking cigarettes yeah so he does smoke
yeah see that's even crazier like how is
he not old as [ __ ] like when people
smoke cigarettes that [ __ ] wears you out
but the people that I see that smoke
cigarettes they look far older there he
is
you seen that mean that people think
there's like pictures their finery is
like oh Kenna Reeves from the 1750
whatever yeah
they photoshopped the [ __ ] out of that
anyway right I watched some crazy [ __ ]
last night Joe run I didn't feel good
I couldn't move much I lost the remote
and I started watching this thing about
the story of the reels [ __ ]
tremendous the reels it's called real
real news or something that's 239 on
cable and they had this whole thing out
about the Godfather [ __ ] interesting
yes [ __ ] jack what was interesting about
what's-his-name didn't want to do the
movie to the director he was a hippie in
San Francisco really had the studio up
there what's his name Francis Ford
Coppola is a
beginning he ain't braggin Guinea he's
happy longer huh
he owns a vineyard ya hippie dude had
the studio and they wanted him to do the
Godfather he's like but he had an
assistant called what's his assistants
name uh
George Lucas was a young assistant
really yeah that was his young assistant
at the time that's crazy that he talked
him into it because he goes at the
building they had was running out of
money had no money to pay the rent Wow
they were gonna run out of the rent so
he talked them into doing it because he
had to pay the rent
look Francis Ford Coppola with r2d2
that's incredible just he was like 24
years old young kids bro young kids I'll
tell you what was a good move that a lot
of people were critical of when they
sold Star Wars to Disney cuz Disney is
taking that [ __ ] and run with it they
run with it I mean they're making so
many more Star Wars movies they're good
[ __ ] movies they're fun they're doing
Star Wars world at Disneyland which
looks insane
they released a preview video of it the
other day have you taken your girl to
Disneyland yet no she hasn't asked you
job said I was I'll play you just wait
I'm that she hasn't she asked about a
month ago tell me when you want to go
and we'll all go together okay yeah yeah
she asked about a month ago
we'll go together it's just stop getting
sick bro oh really just hell for it yeah
usually you know that [ __ ] because we're
going away does she look out the window
how she'd not get carsick no keeps her
from getting we leave early and I don't
feed her
we take her out of the house [ __ ]
soldier style oh that's good and we only
go one hour so that's why we went to
Huntington Beach we're moving to Santa
Barbara that's what I'm gonna do on
those little holidays now that's good
it's gettin the [ __ ] Ali I'm secure
either sit here for Thanksgiving
yeah take it down to hell even beets I
got the nice hotel for kids you drop
them off at eight they surf you could
have the walk to the [ __ ] beach for
them to walk on the on the street and
then I'll go up to Montecito with them
for New Year's I love it yeah yeah yeah
that's it bro call to come back from
Portland that Friday I come back that
there is there left Friday I'm doing the
two shows after Christmas get back cuz
I'm taking
the month to see though to the second
there's nothing around here nothing do
not the dough have you thought about
moving out of here just waiting just
waiting just a wife for another year
another year what are you thinking it
going I don't know
it's Colorado or Lexington Kentucky huh
yeah there's a lot of people here Joey
Diaz seems like it's getting worse - the
thing that freaks me out is the eminent
doom that one day for sure the Earth's
gonna move the [ __ ] water pipes are
gonna break fire is gonna break out it's
gonna for sure we're gonna have a
disaster and when we have a disaster
then we're gonna realize the real
consequences of jamming 20 million
people into a small area that bothers me
well you know all this was going on this
summer and for two or three weeks you'd
watch the news wouldn't you think of
that like we got to be next was sitting
here not cozy [ __ ] warm living room
watching Florida underwater Texas
underwater you know what what's gonna
come to us well the fires in Northern
California were [ __ ] insane hardly
anybody talked about him it's not a ton
of people living up there so people did
it didn't get the amount of press that
it deserved because there was so much
going on and in Texas so much going on
in Florida so much going on in Puerto
Rico but the [ __ ] fires in Northern
California were insane and they couldn't
do a thing about them they didn't have
fire hydrants and a lot of these places
they didn't have access to water and
they were just burning through towns I
think they said hundreds of people are
missing and thousands of buildings were
burnt to the ground and it barely made
the news [ __ ] Puerto Rico is still
without oh yeah they're [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] and they're not getting any
funding and you know how come they're
not getting funding they got some I mean
it's not that they're not getting funny
but they're not getting enough to
rebuild to do what they need to do to
get their infrastructure people don't
understand about Puerto Rico is that you
have someone and be a hold someone and
after that what surrounds these cities
is what you see on TV is these [ __ ]
villages yeah you know did you read the
New York Times article about Cuba know
about the hurricane how good they are
with hurricanes No
you had to read that article practice in
these shits is 1915 well they have to
they're a fun night when I called my
sister my sister was like it was three
days we got killed I got killed and come
away when my dad's from they got [ __ ]
killed that's still in the water but
they don't [ __ ] around they have this
complete if you can look it up New York
Times article it was [ __ ] huge about
how they have the hurricane how did they
handle it community they have it there
they [ __ ] the what's that when they
pull you out and pull you out right away
I mean they just like you didn't hear
about Cuba having a problem
no they got killed but they are so used
to it they have such a great system for
dealing with it they only have four
there you go hurricane tips from yeah
there you go
unbelievable how good is that right
there the water hitting yes that's a
mother :
look at that they got a 1950s car and
the water is like [ __ ] 80 feet in the
air
smashing waves against the side of the
building or the side of the road rather
how cool is that caught it's pretty bad
car how cool is that they take those
cars they put like four cylinder
Diesel's in them too they do all kinds
of crazy [ __ ] with those yawning did you
watch that show when they do the 13
episodes of the Cuban cause no but I've
seen a lot of things I'm really
interesting how they [ __ ] paint they
look like all that [ __ ] that they get my
car and they put the car together pretty
interesting [ __ ] there was a guy who
bought an island outside of Cuba
I forget what Island was but it got hit
so bad by the hurricane that it
completely wiped off everything on the
island this guy some billionaire
character bought the entire island and
for the first time in over 300 years
it's unpopulated there's literally no
one living on this island they went from
being this green lush Ireland to be in
just a big flat patch of dirt like
flattened it just got hit by the full
brunt of the storm right after this to
plot it I mean it I don't know how much
you spent on it except Richard Branson's
Island I don't think so no no I think it
was the guy who owns uh John Paul
Mitchell nectar island completely Oh
nobody knows he's a hat bonking so
Richard Branson says
nectar island completely utterly
devastated by hurricane Airman herma
yeah it's uh I'm sure that Island got
Jack too but there was an island that is
completely unpopulated for the first
time in three hundred years forget what
the island was but these are just gonna
get worse the crazy thing about these
hurricanes is they're building up steam
out in the ocean versus in the Gulf like
usually they would get to the Gulf and
they would build up because the Gulf has
warmer water but the water in the ocean
is getting so warm that think it's the
island of Barbuda I don't think yeah
that's it
I don't think somebody owns that one no
someone just bought it oh really
yeah yeah some guy just bought the
island of Barbuda I think so you've been
thinking about leaving yeah thinking
about stay no I think about leaving all
the time yeah I've been discussing it
open well when it was getting a hundred
nine degrees in [ __ ] October we were
like is this gonna be like in five years
like is this keep gonna keep getting
worse like if climate change is real it
seems to be if we're getting record
temperatures every year which seems to
be happening at least around here you
got a wonder like when that's not
sustainable anymore when you what do you
want to live in Phoenix in August I
don't you know that that Phoenix weather
we've been there before it's 120 degrees
that's not that's not deal about to me
you know we got it we got to assume that
Robert De Niro vows to rebuild the
island of Barbuda after hurricane armor
strikes why is it filled with black
chicks not he owns the year before I
guess he bought a resort there Jamie's
taking over no no oh my god did you ever
see when they did the [ __ ] benefit
for him they did the tribute to Robert
De Niro no and Beyonce got up there with
a [ __ ] miniskirt and start dancing
poor Robert De Niro did go crazy oh my
god you could see him just melting high
lifes and look at that dogs yeah he
loves he loves the sisters he does can't
be Madeleine for that it's kind of sad
interesting is there another famous guy
that's known for love and black chicks
as much as De Niro is no no no he's like
known for it
well you crack jokes about it and
everybody knows the joke right it's loan
free but nobody really says that cuz
it's DeNiro right I'm saying well I mean
it's an obvious flavor it's like I mean
you I can't even think it a single
celebrity that's like known for having a
predilection for Asian chicks name one
okay name another celebrity that's got a
thing for four black chicks its DeNiro
it's like De Niro is the running Wesley
Snipes he's got a thing for asian chicks
fit me thank maybe yeah maybe maybe he's
married to one or something something
yeah but not enough worry like you can
tell a joke about it like De Niro is one
of those guys were like a piece of
information has to be so far distributed
so widely distributed that you can crack
jokes about it and everybody knows what
you're talking about
like that's like the de niro thing it's
gotten to the point where anybody could
crack a joke about it did you prefer any
particular woman tightly I like white
chick yeah yeah I love white chicks
Terry white just love love them love
them love them love them Chinese I like
white dirty white chicks yeah I love Y I
don't know just something but as a kid I
like the Irish chicks I grew up in a
past without I was surrounded with
chicks with freckles and red hair and
sweaty tits I love all that [ __ ] you
know I don't like dirty feet but I like
white chicks you know they say when
you're a kid like the things you're
surrounded by the things that like you
first come in contact with when you
become sexually active that that's sort
of like cements in your brain and a lot
of people but I know those worries and
all those Gina's I can't be with that
Muresan Gina's they get leases Gina's
yeah they wanna fight scream at you and
throw [ __ ] yeah and it there was
something about that that I liked them
they were hotter than [ __ ]
I love the Italian women you know mm-hmm
but I really like white chicks Irish
chicks is my [ __ ]
I love them I [ __ ] love him but to
just like I have a friend that's Jewish
that's all he dates his black chicks you
know really half from The Sopranos yes
what was the old man with yeah yeah I
don't know if you look she's a little
pale for my taste
yeah you know it's just some people I
have a body same thing Jewish guy that's
all marriages ii black chick
yeah oh that's right that's right yeah
yeah yeah that's all I know and it's
funny because you think of like a black
like De Niro he's an older guy you know
he was around I could just imagine the
first time than they were with home oh
yeah I've brought a black chick home his
dad's like you know well maybe not its
dad but how about all those [ __ ]
people that loved him in those movies
all those Ginn's o's you know probably
racist and then loved him and all these
and expected him to be with some [ __ ]
mafia looking lady and he shows up with
some super soul sister well that's why
[ __ ] Bronx Tale was so good he really
put that part of his life in there like
that part with the black chick you know
that kid that went to jail
that's what Bronx Tale was about really
it was about he remember that movie yeah
it was about a Bronx Tale is a good
[ __ ] movie and they we just I hated
the movie theater when I went to see it
I didn't like it and it wasn't for me
but now was on a couple weeks ago that
scene with the bikers that's a great
[ __ ] Saint and that's a true story
that's a true [ __ ] story yeah this
old-school Sammy the bull story but your
bikers were into his bar Sammy came back
told to be cool no clock the door and
said now you can't leave and they just
be ever seen that they just man to
[ __ ] all those bikers and they get
out of that but that movie was about the
kid that was on The Sopranos that going
to prison for murder
what's his colossal oh yeah oh this is
hilarious
with the guy with bad luck his name was
mush some him live in the closet
they wouldn't even I don't want his
money touching my money he's so bad luck
but that whole thing is about him dating
the black Jay and then they go to the
brother member was jaw that that street
in the Bronx where I used to get nickel
bags and whatever
Avenue or that all that [ __ ] up there so
it ends in a black neighborhood so he
would have to walk home and then 1/9 the
walk home is for friends went into a
black name but with the car and they got
blown up you gotta watch this movie
right is it the movie man that Chad's
pulmonary guy he did a lot of [ __ ] and
then he kind of vanished he was still
around he's doing this [ __ ] and Broadway
now what's he doing the Bronx Tale on
Broadway he just took it out see he took
it out new musical
who got him with the gay community look
at their de niro and who's the guy on
the left that's the gay guy we tell the
Bronx Tale yeah this is a good movement
bizarre bizarre number this guy lived at
your boys and they said to go home at
night and tell stories every night so
those guys are pissed because they said
supposedly took some of their stories
Frankie Renzulli and most of his stories
from East Boston actually wound up in
this movie so he did they kind of have
Julie was the kind of a Sopranos right
yeah he's right Sopranos he's written
for a lot of things yeah that world debt
world of guineas and mob movies and mob
stuff it's just like it becomes it's
like an identity in a weird business
it's like an identity that they put on
you know this you know the connected
Italian character identity you know and
like from The Sopranos on that became a
big selling point in Hollywood like it
was a niche you know that people got
excited about like the Italian gangster
movie became a big thing the Italian
gangster films became a big thing and so
there was like a whole bunch of guys
like I'm sure you went out for auditions
and you were around those guys that were
in that loop it's a dumb little it's a
dumb loop it's hilarious it really is
like well they were talking about last
night like look at the Sopranos killed
the Mafia TV show that's it you won't
see another mom will be again for 10
years because they were so good yeah
just covered too many of the babes
you've never seen it again
every once in a while I got a script for
a mom when I want you know Rufus I open
it up if I see Gino Vinny or Tony or
Angelo I close the script because you're
living in a [ __ ] fool's paradise it's
not gonna get made or it's not gonna do
nothing you gotta come and that's why
they haven't been able to figure out the
post Soprano world right there was too
much they got into the Columbus yeah
they even got into Columbus Day
that's how brilliant the [ __ ]
Sopranos were they did an episode about
Columbus Day when they said people down
in the Apollo played the cop and oh yeah
remember that soprano started off as a
comedy yeah oh yeah soprano started off
the first episode was over-the-top
comedy where what's-her-name Edie Falco
was outside with an ak-47 because her
daughter was trying to sneak out yeah
yeah I mean she was a cartoon character
I mean every it was ridiculous and then
slowly but surely it became this are
really intense complicated drama and it
wasn't funny at all
well the mother died and that changed
everything was the first show that
somebody died and changed the course of
it because it would have been completely
different it would have ended with her
being the boss yeah it would have been
the first time or a herb but they went
back to this last night with the
Godfather how they had failed twice to
make a mom movie
Kirk Douglas had done a movie in 67 and
didn't do well so when this Mario Puzo
was [ __ ] the book was tremendous they
sent it to what's-his-name they did not
want Marlon Brando really no they did
not want him Brando had been a dud
he had just done [ __ ] that movie on
the percent that movie where he bought
the island Oh island of dr. Moreau no no
one the big one when he first bought the
island 70 68 I saw when he bought his
own eye right but he shot the movie uh
bounty what is it the treasure I forget
what the name of the movie Monte
Cristo's no they gave a bunch of money
go down there shoot the movie he fell in
love one of the natives so he got like
the first guy hey Jamie come in direct
the movie and he started [ __ ] around
every day so parama wanted
footage with clarify I saw the footage
they saw birds and people run and they
go what happened to our movie so they
kind of like [ __ ] five Brando from
directing it Mountain Beauty mutiny on
the bounty so he was done he we came
back to the states like he was persona
non grata they didn't want to talk to
him no more
you [ __ ] our money you left your wife
with his hot chick on an island yeah
she's hot
yeah once he met her he told his wife to
go [ __ ] this out they're about to go
[ __ ] themselves and he just doesn't hang
out goes full screen with her goddamn I
get it holy [ __ ]
that's what legit huh [ __ ] man she's
[ __ ] hot that's some serious
Polynesian jeans right there baby
so when he came back then well you know
they didn't want Michael either what
they wanted they wanted didn't out one
out but you know you mean for Michael
corioli they were Leone they wanted a
Robert Redford whoa what Oh
or Ryan O'Neal
well that's hilarious that's what they
that's what they want if a rocky that's
a lair I don't deal that's what I want
that answer inmate from 73 to 75 we need
a black actor how about Ryan O'Neal we
need a box
how about Ryan O'Neal they loved Ryan
O'Neal's look so they were gonna put him
rocky you don't even hear about him
anymore
well he's 90,000 [ __ ] years old what
is this cat his original cast list like
people he had written down for what
worthy because Godfather Wow Jimmy Caan
Jimmy so who wrote this list this couple
is less hopeful is less Wow
Cory Leone Marlon Brando underlined he
wanted he wanted out Pacino badly he
just did that movie about the heroin or
something and they want him the the
studio didn't want him no the studio
didn't want him he wanted them but the
studio didn't 1 Wow
so [ __ ] John Saxon wasn't a played
Sonny Corleone that would have charged
Saxon from the editor of the Dragon yeah
like I was a good actor yeah Robert
to vow for time look at list wow that's
amazing yeah there's some movies that
just even today if you try to watch them
there for now phenomenal
that's this one's one of them it's
phenomenal this one's one of them don't
watch the one with the brought back
footage though which ones that
that one that HBO released I don't like
something he tree you could tell how bad
James Caan is as an actor then oh it's
brutal
it's rude have you seen the 8 hour 1 9
HP oh well they put them all together no
they put them all together and they put
all the pieces back in really but you
got a lot to have a lot of time eight
hours yeah it's like six hours there's
no time for that you break it up into
two hour segments but it's pretty
interesting it shows you what really
happened with the father in him like the
father would just torture Michael ah how
you doing how's that little white
girlfriend doing her hysterical he would
there's a scene in the hospital he pulls
them over those little white piece of
[ __ ] did you tell her and then he like
how is those medals one of those
shooting people he's shooting strangers
is [ __ ] and then they go into it opens
up with them at the wedding and they go
from the wedding to the hospital to see
the guy originally called slew the Eddie
and you got to see that scene
the dude is sitting there Brando walks
in and he's like Godfather hold my hand
the Reapers gonna come but if he sees
you he'll be scared like that's how
[ __ ] much they love The Godfather and
maybe he goes listen I'm here with my
four sons
he ain't gonna bother I'm here with your
son somewhere I'm here with my sons to
pay their respects to you he ain't gonna
bother you shows all that [ __ ] the guy
that blew up his wife in Sicily mmm it
shows him getting him and Buffalo now I
really back in yeah he owns a pizza
parlor he gets in the car they blow him
up they show all that [ __ ] so who cut
that stuff out the studio it's too long
yeah you know don't quote me on that
maybe the studio maybe the director hmm
but James Caan scenes are just not too
bueno no you can see he doesn't but
Michaels [ __ ] tough Michael slots all
those dudes
that's when directing was directed if
you've ever done anything bad
in your life you learn anything bad when
you do something bad you know your ears
ring your ears ring o when your
Adrenaline's off-the-charts when you're
hiding in a bush and somebody's coming
towards you you gotta hit them with that
stick you have no idea what happens to
you do you have no idea Joe Rogan that's
why I've always loved the godfather all
those type of movies because when he
comes out of the bathroom you hear the
train screeching G right but that's what
you hear when you open bro when you're
right probably I'm just talking about
hitting somebody the head with a stick
right never mind having to come out of a
restaurant with a gun and shooting two
people I can't imagine where your heart
the way that you just get up and shoot
beep your heart beats that Adrenaline's
going you [ __ ] you don't hear nothing
like why are we still robbing us I can't
hear nothing don't you just your heart
is gone the problem you just go under
your heart takes [ __ ] over you know I
had this I forgot about this I had this
when I was 19 I was an electrician did
you know that an aspirin there was a
dude that used to break my balls all the
time like say stupid things for me he
will always go this to things a buddy I
don't like your Cuban in you from these
coasts so I always knew me and this guy
we're gonna have a little [ __ ]
problem I was 19 he was a little older
than me I always know me and this
[ __ ] have a problem and he'd
always say little things to me look at
my tools out of the bed and I love his
thumb go get him yourself [ __ ] and I
was kind of scared of the guy but I knew
me and him we're gonna battle one day
and one day he said something mean I
told enough go [ __ ] himself when I came
back from lunch you put a box cutter to
my throat he got me as I was coming in
he threw me against the wall he had the
box cutter army I was bigger than
physically and I knew I could [ __ ] him
up I was just scared I was a young kid I
was not in my I was living in basalt
Colorado you know I was not on my turf
with my friends but after he put that
knife to my throat I'll never forget
that I I [ __ ] like when he stepped
away that thing came into my mind where
if you pull your gun out use it like
that thing came up at that and I go I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill this guy I'm gonna do
something bad for this guy and I had a
guy used to shoot with
taught me how to shoot guns he was a
Vietnam vet and on the weekends I would
give him money he'd teach me to shoot
everything a arse and [ __ ] a K he
taught he had every weapon he was just a
Vietnam vet to live than aspirin and I
finally figured out why they put all
those Vietnam vets around Aspen and
Colorado why NORAD yeah NORAD so they
could be ready to [ __ ] rock I never
thought about that you know everybody
thinks that if we get hit we're gonna
hit California in New York the most
strategic place to it would be NORAD
wouldn't it cuz they control everything
out of Colorado and under that [ __ ]
mountain
let's read up about I don't know [ __ ]
about that
yeah like that was years ago they always
said we will get a hit will you hit
Colorado so what happened with you and
the guy in the box
man the guy in the box cut I kept
[ __ ] like I was scared of this guy
Joe Rome and I was definitely scared of
this guy but at that time I wanted to
kill my stepfather so I went to my
friend the guy I was teaching me how to
shooting [ __ ] and I told him about what
happened he goes well if you're thinking
of shooting his stepfather why don't you
use this guy's practice well what's the
difference if you're gonna go back to
New Jersey and spoke his stepfather and
shoot him start with this guy use him
his [ __ ] practice either I'm saying I
was a little [ __ ] I thought about but I
don't like the guy put a knife to my
throat I [ __ ] didn't like that Jerome
at all I said I'm gonna get this guy so
I was cool to him at work I let him go
to work this went on I figured I'd get
him over the holidays he was a boozer
and he went to this little bar in
Carbondale all the time and I think I
might get him down there so I went to
Fred I don't teach me everything I need
to do to get this guy down he goes we're
gonna get you out as quick as I could
possible and he's the first guy never
taught me a hanger you whip somebody
with a [ __ ] hanger it's all over you
take the handle whip it tape the other
side and just come on at dark with a
hanger they don't see nothing all they
see is this that's all they see they
don't see a [ __ ] hanger you know I'm
saying I never forget I stopped this guy
for like [ __ ] a week man and I
finally [ __ ] call him Charlie and you
know I couldn't hear for like two days
after I hit him with that anger so you
beat him up with a hanger I bit him up
with a hanger and a [ __ ] sticks
fighting stick a fighting stick you have
those you know like Paulie yeah you know
collie sticks yeah
I took one of those I put it on my
jacket and I whipped them with the
hanger first when he got out of his car
and then when he went down I whipped
them in the legs dog I pissed my pants I
had [ __ ] in my ass
fear is a [ __ ] like even when
you're winning fear is a [ __ ]
and I couldn't here for two days out and
what happened the dude never came back
to work really I went back after the
holidays thinking I was going to
arrested that day because I did it well
I had the mask with the holes I did it
perfectly
oh I threw all the clothes away down in
Glenwood Springs I got rid of everything
you know me I had this teacher that
taught me everything he goes if you
don't have blood on your clothing be in
a sweat get it rid of everything so I
had a bag in the car I went down Valley
and got through my clothes as I went
down the Aeneid you ever go up and down
82 if you go from Glenwood Springs up to
Aspen that's one of the worst roads in
the country I just drew my clothes out
of there if I was an 18 19 this guy had
to be like 31 bro I could smell the [ __ ]
I was just whipping him at night with
that woman so I took the stick out and I
hit him in the legs a few times and I
got close to my said don't tell him less
to nobody
oh I'll [ __ ] come back and beat you
again because I didn't want him to hear
my voice I went back after holidays he
was they never came back to work the guy
sent somebody down at his house and
never came back but I was so deaf like
there's been a couple times that my
hearing has been gone because of
something bad that I've done and the
[ __ ] my heartbeat and the adrenaline
or you hear is like a [ __ ] beep well
most people are just not used to that
kind of confrontation you know well the
average person I just couldn't let him
get away with that that little
[ __ ] you know I never saw him
again after that never saw him again
move to everything he moved I was
[ __ ] pickles for a couple of weeks
he come get me no it was you I don't
know really I don't know I gave him like
a three month window after them
I wanted him to think I want him to
forget about it like I was gonna do it
the right way that's how you do it
all right you know Wow
I imagine that was you at 19 like
imagine like stop this is points in your
life where you go was that even really
me I mean I know it was me
because I have the memory of it I know
it was my physical body back then but
wasn't really me don't what I was trying
to write the book I would read like well
that those chapters I would read it two
days later and I would have to stop
Giroux because it didn't stop like it
didn't sound like when I was in high
school or I go from robbing a gas
station for my buddy losing $60,000 now
we had to rob somebody get the money
that I was in a flight to Sarasota
Florida and then the people you know
when I was 18 I robbed a jewelry store
and I had to go away I got a call one
day anything goes come back the guy got
it all taken care of the guy got and
didn't arrest you in 60 days so he filed
an insurance report now they can't
arrest you you know like I learned about
all those things at a young age like
what a scam
so the guy knew I robbed them and then
afterward a friend of mine tell me this
guy bumped into that guy in the
Christmas party he was happy you robbed
him he goes he wanted you to rob he just
didn't want you to come back because
then you get arrested and had to pay
restitution what can I afford five hours
a week right if he collects the
insurance he gets a big lump sum payment
plus he could liable what was in there
so I was doing him a favor
no [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy what you learn man
what you learn as a [ __ ] young I was
[ __ ] up Jerome this is amazing that
you got through it all though that's the
really crazy thing you got through it
all pretty unscathed
no physic cost me a couple years of my
life costing my daughter cost me nobody
is in my life that I'm what am i early
don't you I got arrested well I got
arrested for the kidnapping then I had
the kid and then
I had my beef with him you know I had
the beef with him when he called me a
[ __ ] and I smacked them and I had two
families already they were gonna throw
me in jail for [ __ ] him being the guy
that was Daniels John your ex-wife and
when you have two felonies one more but
he couldn't in the city of thank God for
Balder and liberals thank God for
Boulder and liberals you can't use a
racial slur and inside the city limits a
boulder really because there you go
because the University Colorado when
that chick called JJ flamming and the
[ __ ] and he smacked it and he got away
with it on Monday at court because she
so the same check what was that story
some white chick was drunk coming out of
a [ __ ] pole goes one of those 18 and
over bars and she got into an argument
with JJ Flannigan my corner you know it
was racist
JJ finding was a football player at the
time for the University of Colorado from
do you ever see that that from like 9 89
to 93 that a lot of problems in Colorado
they were getting called criminals but
what it was it was just three black guys
walking down you know [ __ ] Boulder at
11 o'clock at night cops pull over one
of them says racism they get into a
fight I mean don't get me wrong nobody
was angels that [ __ ] one line back of
the head can a mr. McGee somebody called
him a yah one time he punched him in the
face so hard he broke the guy's eye
socket that guy ended up going to the
[ __ ] New York Giants as a linebacker
but that's how bad that cop prom with
the college football players it was that
bad and boulderon at one time so when I
went to court and the guy goes there's
no charges here even the cops wouldn't
charge and they wrote me a summons to go
to court but they wouldn't charge me for
smack in the [ __ ] dude then right
after that I knew you know what man if I
stay I'm gonna go to jail that's number
one number two I really wanted to do
comedy I really wanted to give Tommy a
shot you know I was like I gotta give
Tommy a shot hey how old were you 32
years old I got on stage the first time
1991 so how long is that 26 she is yeah
26 she is so the first time I [ __ ]
around for the first two years but like
by 93 I got really serious about
that's when I went back to be a dad I
was really serious about that I had a
good job but they kept [ __ ] with me but
that one day when he called me a [ __ ]
and I smacked them that changed
everything I was like that's never gonna
be the same I saw my little girl cry and
you know she's here all up in that I
grew up in that world with people
getting smacked you know she didn't grow
up in that so I just said listen I'm
never gonna win this [ __ ] war this is
gonna be a war that I might either end
up in jail or something good and I'm
gonna kill one of these [ __ ] I might as
well give comedy shot what do they have
to lose it's this crazy thing that that
was your option and then think about all
the [ __ ] that you've been through now
like thinking of yourself back then you
know I mean what do you think about
today like your life with your little
daughter and your wife and you know
doing podcasts and doing all these shows
everywhere and then just thinking like
holding someone hostage kidnapping them
robbing a drug dealer the machine gun
and we just think that was you it's it's
weird because that's not you
you are right now no no but you have
these memories of things that you did I
used a weapon like four times to bust
and to drug the others house all the
things that could happen
oh yeah easily I mean the other times I
would just rob them just because who I
was I don't give a [ __ ] what are you
doing man I'm just like thinking about
that guy that pulled the knife on you
what if after you beat him he came back
and tried to get you and then escalated
and the next thing you know he stabbed
him where he shot him or easily could
emerge I was so confused at that time in
1919 everybody's confused at 19 but 19
and been through the [ __ ] you know as I
confused as I was I was really [ __ ]
confused so I I was you know from I
think till 20-something I wanted to kill
my stepdad and that was why what was it
that was all that was getting consumed
with me like that that was my
consumption like the pain I was going
through without my mom the drugs and
killing my stepdad well why you stepdad
what does it was about my mom died
without a will my mom didn't leave a
will so he took all the money all the
jewelry he didn't give me a piece I
didn't collect Social Security
you know I didn't get my real father
died my real father was the first Cuban
committeeman in Union City all right and
he was doing coke in 1966 and somebody
gave him a package there was pure heroin
a little wine and that he died they took
him to the hospital and they never
signed the death certificate in Union
City New Jersey so they forced my mother
to take him back to Cuba 1967 my mom had
to take my dad my dad's buried in Cuba
Wow
but guess what my dad got an insurance
policy and then and the debt the coroner
never signed the death certificate so I
never got that Prudential Insurance plus
my mom all properly with Miami Airport
is my mom had that property with to our
drug partners where that [ __ ] thing
was and I didn't get my cut from that so
I wanted to kill the guy so for years
that was my whole thing you know when I
went to Colorado and hooked up with Fred
and he taught me how to shoot and not a
[ __ ] you know shoot a [ __ ] rifle
and measure distance and all that [ __ ]
they do on TV that was me what did you
step down say did you ever talk to him
we ended up talking and [ __ ] you know
what man he was the type of person he
was and I wasn't gonna get [ __ ] and
after a while I accepted it I was like
you know what I'm putting too much stock
into this [ __ ] this I'm gonna go make my
own money do you know I'm saying like
sometimes we get stuck and I'm happy I
didn't get no money because I wouldn't
have been the person I am today yeah I'm
happy I didn't get any money I'm not
funny like that's one of the worst
things you can do is like win the
lottery or get a big inheritance you
think getting a big inheritance would be
amazing for you it's one of the worst
things that can happen terms of like
your ambition if you're in the middle of
doing something you've got some ideas or
maybe you don't know what you want to do
and you need to find something you're
hungry then all sudden you just get a
giant chunk of money and now you're
buying things and your ambitions gone
you don't know what to do I don't mind
giving somebody startup money you know
you have to give you a child some type
of startup money
you know something wrong with that but
I'm socking about like winning the
lottery
like people win the lottery it's like
there's a giant percentage of them that
ruined their life giant like they've
done all these Studies on people winning
a lot so what is it because I'm giving
you a bunch of money you didn't earn it
like I'm giving you a bunch of money is
that what it is yeah for sure like think
about you and all the money that you've
earned in your life you've earned it you
do all these shows you've you've built
up a successful stand-up career you
built up a successful podcast you've
done a lot of film and TV you've worked
you've worked right you've gathered up
and you make a good living now you know
but this is all from work right there's
a build-up to it it makes sense in your
head there's an effort there's a reward
for that effort there's motivation
there's discipline there's focus and
then there's a payoff for all that if
you just get the payoff with no
discipline no focus no lessons learned
it's just not a healthy way to exist
it's terrible that's why rich kids are
so [ __ ] up rich kids that grow up with
trust funds are all [ __ ] not all of
them a giant persistent [ __ ] died I knew
a guy who was a rich guy and his parents
were [ __ ] billionaires and he grew up
with two trust funds he burned through
his first trust fund [ __ ] that up and
then they had a backup trust fund for
him he was buying houses and flipping
them and losing money and investing in
businesses and they all went under he
had no discipline no understanding of
what money really was and no hunger
because he never had a time in his life
when he was poor he never had a time in
his life where he's worried about paying
the bills and if you don't have that and
you don't have that real motivation I
just don't think you ever really
appreciate success the people I think
that appreciate success of the people
that worked for it you know what you you
can remember back when you were poor
like I've had people say to me like why
do you do so many jobs why do you have
so many things you do like what why do
you keep moving why do you do so much
because I remember being scared
I remember being broke I remember having
no idea where the [ __ ] the money was
coming from or what my future was gonna
be and I was always terrified of being a
loser that's that feeling of not
succeeding is what motivates you that
know knowing that you failed in the past
and that you know there's been many
times where like how many times are you
bombed and you you get off stage you
like
do this I'm not a comedian I'm [ __ ]
terrible like I got to figure out what
the [ __ ] I'm doing with my life if you
don't go through those things if you
don't have those experiences if you
don't have those moments in your life
where you're unsure of the future you're
not going to have the real resolve that
it takes to make it the grit and
determination that it takes to move
forward and if you don't have that any
success that you do have you're not
gonna appreciate nothing comes easy and
if it does come easy it's not you don't
have it you don't really have it nothing
comes easy so funny how I would never
stick with you Jitsu for what's
understand them I would have quit
jiu-jitsu ass cuz it's so hard because I
would have thought I wouldn't be able to
do it yeah once you try something I
can't do this you're dead right but we
come how [ __ ] scary huh how weird is
it that you and I chose a career that
basically for the first three years
we're not gonna get it done not a dime
and no no certainty at all I don't
nobody understands that like nobody
understands that that that you're not
gonna get a [ __ ] job not only that
there's no pathway it's like if you want
to be a doctor you go to college you get
a degree you go to medical school you do
your residency there's a pathway the
pathway is it's it's hard work it's very
difficult to do not everyone's gonna get
through it successfully but at least
there's a pathway what the [ __ ] is the
pathway for being a successful comedian
your pathway is different than mine
mine's different than Junkins Duncan's
door Ari's we all have different
pathways we all have different styles we
all have different points of view we all
have different ways we deliver material
but all have different ways of writing
no one can tell you what to do when
you're first cut into this did you think
of any success honestly what did you
think the outcome was gonna because for
me I thought that I was just gonna be a
road comic and if I was an extra in a
movie that would be the best I would get
for me like that's the honest truth
you know Fitzsimmons and I was talking
were talking about this recently cuz
Fitzsimmons and I started out exactly at
the same time our number one goal was
being a professional like getting paid
not having a day job that was the goal
being able to pay your bills that was
Michael that's not having a day job yeah
I didn't care if I made 80,000 of 22 no
there was no no no
no no it was no like I want to buy a
mansion or no I just want to be huh I
want to be happy I didn't want a day job
and I knew one other thing when I got in
that car
in June of 95 and I got on 30th Street
in Boulder and I headed out on iris
there's a gas station there and I
probably had when I took my cuz that I
left on a thing of a Tribble run you
know that right that's where you left
Colorado yeah like the time people with
Tribble all right I met a girl in
Michigan that was nasty
hot little dirty strike girl white girl
Carol and then she came to Colorado
threw me a little dose of that monkey
got me all crazy and then she went to
Seattle I was having so many problems in
Denver that it just there was no listen
I love my little girl I believe that I
could've been a good dad it just wasn't
gonna work it just wasn't gonna work
this was gonna end of it this was not
gonna hang good this and all I kept
saying was that picture Mickey Rourke at
the end the [ __ ] angel heart when
he's sitting there smoking his cigarette
with a razor in his hand
blood all over them that's all I kept
thinking about I go you know what I'm
gonna go to Seattle for summer
hang out with this broad but in my heart
I knew I wasn't gonna come back I knew I
wasn't gonna come back so much that I
had two licenses you know yeah you buy
out you know you lose the license and
then one day you find it and by that
time you're already got license yeah I
must have like $69 on me when I left
bald and I had to get the Hodgdon Utah
that was my first road Grigg ever for
David Tribble armed in Utah
I think it was like a 10-hour Drive
maybe longer how long had you been doing
stand-up at that point two years so you
start in Denver I started 91 and now is
95 but you gotta remember from 91 to 93
I was a part-time comic I sold valiums
you want to buy coke meet me at the
broker I saw your coke when I'm doing 10
minutes I didn't write I didn't really
know anything about copy I just knew I
wanted to be a convict I had a business
card and I told people in the big
that was his wine but then I did a stent
in New York for nine months in 93 and
that's where I really got a hint
I took a stand-up comedy class you ready
for this the guy took the stand-up
comedy class a New York Comedy Club in
1993 I trained with him now in jujitsu
really moved to Boulder he's a comedy
writer in town first couple of times I
went to neighs my aides were both oldest
[ __ ] he's I think he's two years older
than he's got white hair and one day I
go he kept calling himself Frank Frank
Frank Frank and I'm on top of him and I
go you [ __ ] Lee Frank
I took your riding course I never forgot
what Wow when realize why you were
rolling with him while I was wrong with
him and he told me he's friends with you
he opened for you at the tree house a
greenery or some kinetic yeah he worked
with you so now we're tight now if I see
him at jujitsu we talk about comedy and
so I took his stand and when I took his
stand-up comedy class that's when it hit
because he said something that hit home
he goes stand-up comedy is how your
world collides with the rest of the
world plain and simple hmm I took that
home and I thought about it I'm like
[ __ ] make sense and then a week later
I went into your old triple in let me
yeah a little triple in for that
yeah old triple in is a [ __ ] dive
they used to do an open mic from
midnight to 4:00 in the morning in like
alcohol ville can you look it up for me
it's it it's our lines but it's closed
what places it's in Manhattan it's not
there anymore you'll see it yeah all
triple wind and it did open mics there
just people falling asleep you know you
wanted that 12 like I will drive a limo
man so I would get to the corner of 12
sign my name up and the guy would go
three hours I gotta come back in three
hours it's midnight so I would take the
limo go to Harlan Dwyre package of coke
maybe buy refre and then I would go
there and do my last spot for the night
look the old triple and Wow look at that
place there's
then an open mic there from 12:00 to
4:00 in the morning
look wow that's crazy so I go well p.m.
to 4:00 a.m. holy [ __ ] this is 1993 I
got nothing going on I'm depressed I'm
driving a limo I'm snorting coke every
night I'm living in a little cot and I
go in there one man who's in there
probably John Leguizamo he's on stage
just talking but when I was sitting
there watching number I noticed
something there was eight people in the
audience but in his world there was
Madison Square Garden like he didn't
give a [ __ ] Joe it's like when you do a
Comedy Store late and there's six people
and people you get off and you like
people like that was great brochure was
great cuz I believe I was at the god
yeah if you think about six people at
the store you're not gonna be you you
can't think about it that way you know
when Paul Mooney like when I Paul Mooney
always intimidated the [ __ ] out of me me
too because I always knew that he was a
writer for Pryor and he was like the
elder statesman to the comedy store back
in 94 when I first started there and I
always had this feeling around him like
I was always nervous around him you know
and when I first started there you know
I was this young white guy in my 20s I
wasn't very good you know I didn't I
didn't get any respect from him you know
and then one day he saw me doing a late
night spot like 1 o'clock in the morning
and there was only like [ __ ] 15 20
people in the audience but I was just
doing my best I was doing I was doing it
and and I heard in the back of the room
he was laughing he was laughing at my
[ __ ] and then I got offstage and he came
up to me after the show and he goes he
goes you are a real comic he goes you
did that show like it was a packed
[ __ ] room that's it and he goes
and you killed those people he goes you
killed those people he goes you were a
real [ __ ] comic and he walked
away and I remember feeling so good like
I can't believe Paul Mooney just gave me
a compliment like he told me I was a
real comic like I was in and then ever
since then give me hugs every time you
saw me you know and this is like you get
that pat on the back or that you know
that thumbs up from someone who your
expect that that means the world man
that's gigantic that's so huge I mean
when someone does that to you that the
just of the wind in your sails you know
it just can take you to a totally
different place cuz you you got the you
got the stamp you know you got a stamp
of approval from someone who's real I'll
never forget that I didn't know the
power of the commies though like I had
no I read about it I heard about it from
you and other people
I didn't Miami with Mooney this has to
be baby 2003-2004 and I opened from you
know it's a two-man show it's just being
him at the Miami improv and I'm on stage
and I just happen to catch a [ __ ] I
just have my catch a [ __ ] you know
the energy thing just killing well you
you used to crush there because you
would do half your punchlines in Spanish
I'm killing but I'm being dirty and I
hear the door open and Paul Mooney I
could see him walking in and he looks at
me and I'm killing I don't having a good
set he's killing me looking at me and he
went out in the hallway bro and the door
was open and he kept yelling to the
staff look at him I'm like [ __ ] maybe
I'm being too dirty right maybe he's
gonna complain about me I can probably
complain the bomb they told me this
isn't true right I've known him from the
store for five [ __ ] years Tom he's
not I think when I'm too dirty and [ __ ]
when I got there he mean when he came up
give keep it going one more time for my
little brother I got off the stage and I
go what happened on the air he was he
was back there yelling [ __ ] the [ __ ]
him props you don't taught him how to be
like that that's Mitzi shore
[ __ ] that's the Comedy Store he
was back there yelling that's the Comedy
Store you win props you don't develop
dick that's the cop you listen to that
that's the Comedy Store that's what
happens when you hang on at the Comedy
Store
that's why that little fat [ __ ]
killing me cuz that's a [ __ ] Comedy
Store and that you know you're right
that feels tremendous one [ __ ]
he's in your Kawana it feels great yeah
he's he was something special he would
own the room to Paul Mooney would sit
down it didn't matter what time he went
up didn't matter how many people in the
audience who would sit down he had a
little tiny bottle champagne and he
would take his [ __ ] time it would
take his time so much oh yeah how to
control a room how to control not not
control overall meaning like you know
you're control freak
but how to get everybody to pay
attention and lock into your thoughts
like he didn't try to to do a song and a
dance for people if y'all look at me
look at me look at me he would just
command presence with excellence this
material was excellent his delivery was
excellent he was calm and composed and
you just always felt like you were
trying too hard when you would watch him
you like I gotta figure out who's doing
you're right that's what he did teach ya
because I give a [ __ ] he didn't give a
[ __ ] but he looked legitimately didn't
give a [ __ ] and boy that guy got stole
from a lot a lot man see I used to steal
all his [ __ ] switch out the word [ __ ]
put in the word Mexican switch it up
about Star Wars and about this and about
that
he just and you would see the different
cuz Mooney would go on after Mencia to
like Mencia would go on before him and
do his [ __ ] and Mooney would go on
afterward you can give a [ __ ] just did
his [ __ ] but he knew it he would be very
frustrated by it you know he was uh it
was a big influence to a lot of us that
got to see and watch him because we all
knew his history I mean he was one of
the head writers for arguably the
greatest comedian of all time you know I
mean he was one of the you feel yeah
Richard Pryor you don't think this I
feel it too but there's a big argument
people always wanna start an argument
with the other dude who had all those
specials what's his name I can't think
it was George Carlin yeah I look hot -
Richard Pryor Oh something odd to me
it's clear it's clear as day it's not
this is not a knock on George Carlin who
was a great comedian he's a great
communicator sharland to me was
more of a social spokesman like he was a
social commentator and he was a very
great comedian as well he had some funny
material for sure but George Carlin did
a special every year every year he did a
special and I think you know his body of
work is certainly larger than anybody
else's
he's certainly one of the all-time
greats but to me there was something
about Pryor that was just so special and
unique and powerful and just just
resonated man I never I'll never forget
listening to his stuff and I was a
little kid me and my girlfriend in high
school I think I was like 16 she was 15
and we were in my room listening to
Richard Pryor on a cassette and just cry
and laugh and sitting on my bed laughing
and laughing and I'll never forget I'll
never forget going to see him my parents
took me to see live on the Sunset Strip
when I was like 14 or 13 or something
like that I'll never forget being in
that movie theater laughing so [ __ ]
hard and looking around at people like
walking back and forth on their chairs
and all I remember thinking is I can't
believe this guy's just talking like
I've seen all these amazing movies like
you know back to school or stripes or
you know name the comedy movies that
you've seen what all these years I saw
these comedy movies that were great and
funny but they were never this funny
like this guy's just talking I'm like
this has got to be the funniest [ __ ] of
all time and he's just talking and
especially when yes this is 82 okay so I
guess I was 15 so it's 14 or 15 that's
when he came out was he - yeah so I was
15 so watching this as a teenager are it
planted the seed in my head like holy
[ __ ] like how is it possible that this
guy can do this that he can just talk
and that talking and just explaining
your life experiences could be so
hilarious that's the seed that was
planted in my head I mean I never
thought I was going to be a comedian I
never never had any aspirations you know
my friend dr. Steve Steve Graham
yes he just called me we just
communicate he's still one of my best
friends to this day and will be to the
dad die because that guy is the guy
talking and doing comedy I was training
that's when I was competing and I just
loved comedy as a fan just loved comedy
and I would always make fun of people
and do like impressions of people having
sex like our friends like like you know
I would just try to make everybody laugh
you know we were all gathered around the
locker room everybody be nervous before
sparring or everybody be nervous when
we're on our way to fights and
tournaments and stuff like that and I
would be the guy who made everybody
laugh and he pulled me aside and he just
said you could be a comedian like you're
really funny
it's like you could really do this and I
said I remember saying you think I'm
funny because you liked me I go other
people are gonna think I'm an [ __ ]
I say [ __ ] up things like I say [ __ ]
up things because I'm around all these
savages
you know I'm around like Leroy Rodriguez
and I had a friend named major battle
that was his name his real name was
major battle he's one of J Kim's black
belts Larry Jones all these guys were
savages and they were just fighters you
know and so I could say [ __ ] up things
around them because they were used to
kicking people in the head they were
used to fighting in tournaments and
taking you know taking bus trips to go
kick the [ __ ] out of people I mean that
was what they did that's what everybody
did back then so the way I felt about it
was like I'm making a group of very
crazy people laughs like these are like
we're all misfits you know we were all
like people that didn't fit in in a
normal world because we were just
fighting and I'm like they'll laugh
because they're crazy
and they're out there punching people
and kicking people and this is a
different world I'm like other people
are not gonna think I'm funny but he
talked me into it and so from there I
started writing some stuff down I waited
about six months till I turned 21 I went
to an open mic and then after I turned
21 like maybe was it 16 days later I
went onstage I turned 21 August 11 1988
and then August 27th I went onstage
yeah but that was just a hundred percent
someone telling me to do it a hundred
percent I always loved it I used to
watch evening at the improv and I would
always watch stand-up on The Tonight
Show but I just loved it like the way I
like music now you know like I love
watching music or listening to music I
don't have any talent I don't have any
aspirations but I love I just love music
to me it's just it does something to me
it makes me feel good I'm a fan of it
you know I'm a fan of a lot of [ __ ] and
I'll never do but stand up it was just
one of those things like I just love
doing it and I would uh you know it
would just be my number one source of
like release as far as like
entertainment it's funny that you say
that about words because for me I was
listening to the Beatles with my buddy
and I got an older brother that was a
junkie that's how I discovered Richard
Pryor oh really we were listening to the
Beatles like I wanna hold your hand and
we're like this is cool his brother came
rising what the [ __ ] you [ __ ]
listening to her well like we'll listen
to The Beatles you know we're all
excited he's like take that [ __ ] off
they took this album cover out with a
black dude on it I honestly put some on
I hear this [ __ ] laughter and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] awesome come
and kind of stage you know Richard Pryor
and you're like and after that first
side I was done like once I heard the
wino meets Dracula there's something I
said that's what that's that was my I
don't know what I'm if it's the [ __ ]
crazy well why don't meets Dracula I
don't know what I'm exactly is this
something I said all the [ __ ] crazy
those are the 12 I don't know which one
when I heard the last cut on it which is
the wino meets Dracula I was hooked I
left there I bought the album I brought
it home that I bought some Bicentennial
mega and there's a there's a friend of
mine ray Cannella who I still talk to he
was a VP of sci-fi and he goes do you
still remember coming on my house in the
sixth grade and your mother catching us
listening to his mother and I wasn't
allowed now don't you remember that [ __ ]
we used to have a band I used to be a
singer
Ben sixth grade really rakin Aladin
lip-read John bender
what kind of music the Beatles wow the
Beatles I want to hold your hand help I
need somebody yeah the dig is great but
that nigger's crazy look at the title
they put like an asteroid where the pie
is like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
people but meanwhile it says it on the
album like they have the picture where
you see him on the album and it says ni
Jie GE R but then they have the actual
title for sale what's the website this
was that's a yell peace calm oh that's
an LP you can get that in vinyl oh yeah
Wow look at that face - who's young then
man he's like in his 30s Gaudi was good
see to me it's like I have this is my
version of my like evolutionary chart of
comedy I think the guy who started it
all off as Lenny Bruce Lee - so I have
Lenny Bruce posters framed on my wall I
mean like I just feel like I don't like
I don't enjoy watching him or listening
to him as much because I don't think he
was as good today because I think that
the culture was so different back then
that it's not it's very difficult for us
to to see like the things that he's
saying are not groundbreaking today
because he already broke that ground and
then the culture shifted with it I mean
it's not just him but a lot of other
people a lot of other authors and
politicians all these different people
broke different ground and cultures
evolved since then but I think Richard
Pryor took what he did in the honesty
that Lenny Bruce exhibited on stage and
he brought it to the next level you know
he took it to a new place and I think
that that happens a lot when people are
influenced by other people I think
that's one of the things that's really
important the distinction between being
influenced and stealing you know I think
we all influence each other and I know
you guys influence me like Ari and
Duncan and you and all of us together
you know Tom Burtt we influence each
other and that we inspire each other and
that when you see someone do really
stuff like you want to do more bird does
it to me
you know Louie you see someone doing
really wood Chappell you see really good
comedy you want to do more really good
comedy and everyone sort of influencing
everybody so I think that honesty that
Lenny Bruce expressed was so unique for
the time that there was no one had ever
done any sort of social commentary in in
a comedy form the way that Lenny had
done so and then Richard Pryor took it
and just blew it out of the water I mean
Richard Pryor was raised the brothels he
was raised in a brothel Joey he was
raised in a whorehouse in Peoria
Illinois I mean Richard Pryor was
experiencing life in a different way you
know in all his experiences with drugs
and craziness and wild people growing up
and then you know the the comedy of the
time-shifting from the 60s into the 70s
it became this thing that he was at the
forefront of and in my opinion he's like
the most revolutionary figure in all
comedy he is he he was just so different
and so unique and so polished you know I
remember I was a I was living with my
roommates and like because it was like
87 or something like that we have this
place in in Revere we're all living
together wasn't Malden malt we're living
oh no it was Lynn Lynn Massachusetts
near the beach and we all watched a Sam
Kinison special which was hilarious it
was really funny but then we watched
prior after we watched Kennison and we
were like wow like look how much
smoother Pryor is like that's what I
remember thinking and remember my friend
Billy goes look how much more polished
he is I'm like that's the word right
it's like polished he's like yeah he's
like smooth there he was smoother he
just had a different sort of style
whereas Kennison was just Kinnison was
just kick-starting everything and just
[ __ ] knock you know this guy you see
him coming but Lenny what's his name
what's the first guy he's like Lenny
Bruce I like Lenny Bruce I don't think
his materials
rages but I like this cadence yeah yeah
man you know a man yeah I told her yeah
I listen he's got some jokes that hold
up
listen champ you know yeah I come back
in a little while see because he sent a
word slap I don't know if you know the
word see stamp is a great word because
he's yeah my wallet and I like how they
shot his specials
I like how they shot him I like I like
that black and white somebody just gave
me in one of the towns gave me him live
in Carnegie Hall it's got you know yes
Wow after why you said thingy or should
I shoot myself but there's a couple
piece in there will you see it man I
read that book that land ladies and
gentlemen that's a book that that's a
great hook the one about the hotel in
New York and how he oh you know you did
jazz music you know shooting heroin all
day hanging file on the windows the
windows copy that ladies and gentlemen
love was a [ __ ] I love all this [ __ ]
that's what made me become Ambani my
wife sure used to look good standing up
against this thing she's the lowest
though I really put her down no no I
really miss her I don't want some sharp
chick that can quote Kerouac and walk
with boys I just want to hear my old
lady say get up and fix this thing it's
still making noise
what the [ __ ] is this dog it's just this
is godly yeah this one he was just doing
weird shower [ __ ] me out he was he
has a joke today that still holds up
about gay people he goes dig the
homosexuals he goes they lock him up in
jail before being gay where they put him
in there with a bunch of men who won't
have sex with him give you some volume
on this
[Music]
no I promise continuity I'll behave
myself I'll do all the lines where he
hurt you know
that's the thing you know I have a
reputation for being sort of
controversial and irreverent and also
the semantics bear trap of bad taste and
actually I do have and I will always be
accused of bad taste by the people who
eat and rest service you know that kind
of scene to anyone yet but you might be
interested in how I became offensive
like started in school with a drinking
and I was really I was like good real
depressed kids you know seven eight
years old I really get juiced and so the
teacher would really get bugged you know
with with me singing and carrying on
calling Columbus of things younger and
boosting Aaron Burr and then smoking I
don't know if you can see can you see
that from here I've got like them this
tattoo here I fix a youtube I see I
smoke Marlboros and I was six years old
and it grew up there semantics there are
words that offend me let's see Governor
Faubus segregation offend me a nighttime
television offends me sometimes the
shows that exploit homosexuality
narcotics and prostitution under the
guise of helping the societal problem in
the accept like for a few shows one guy
on the coast has got like a nutty sense
of you may know his name is Paul Coates
and he found out dig like there were
kids that eight and nine years old that
was sniffing airplane glue
[Music]
you get higher you know and
I had sort of a fantasy how it happened
the kid is alone in his room and it's
Saturday
the child is played by George McCready
what else do you know I were alone in
the room and it's Saturday
mother's away and what'll I do that's
good in hospitals I'll make an airplane
that's good out it's hard to like it's
you know I'm saying it doesn't really
translate today because just we're just
this was irreverent and crazy back then
but today we're like hmm very
interesting yeah he was getting it he
was doing it well this thing
it's historic right so you're watching
this and you're hearing people laugh and
you got to put your eat it's it's
impossible to enjoy this without
understanding the context of the time
that he was doing it like you have to
kind of like put yourself at the time
where all this was taking place whereas
I think prior stuff still translates
today you know there's a lot of prior
material that you'll watch today and
you'll still laugh your ass off stuff of
him going back to Africa stuff of him
shooting his car cuz his girlfriend's
trying to leave so he shot the car like
he's got some some bits that are still
to this day like and you know he
massively influenced Eddie Murphy
massively influenced Chris Rock who was
influenced by Eddie Murphy you know I
mean he's I think he's the cornerstone I
think he's the big cornerstone to stand
up I'm happy you said that I feel the
same way I thought that you were gonna I
like George Carlin I think George Carlin
a great Adamic sure but he wasn't my
Richard Pryor Richard Bryan my [ __ ]
down I love for me for me is Pryor and
then it was Kinnison after Pryor
McKenna's I think Kinnison for a couple
of years was just a monster monster that
HBO special yeah still one of mine that
was the first out the liner what's the
name of that live from hell yeah yeah
that's - other than hell [ __ ]
tremendum here listen dice is first
special oh yeah it's a [ __ ] tank
there's some specials that they just
they all that I used to watch when I
used to go to that fourth they used to
be a movie room rental place on 28th
Street in Boulder it was three floors it
was the biggest video store on the west
coast
years ago they had everything I rented
that Rodney special from them so much
you know what else I rented the best of
B et for Joe Torre so tell Ari Joe Torre
was the warm-up then before but when he
had his own no no because in those days
yeah what's his name was the host of the
show for Def Jam before yeah who was the
host of Def Jam they used to have Joe
Torre it was Jack back then remember
that he would do Slyke sleeveless shirts
he'd have giant ass [ __ ] arm Jack he
was in that movie Janet Jackson yes
that's what he was shot with Tupac and
[ __ ] in the the Janet Jackson's Mexican
boy forget Steve you yet some pictures
of video of Joe Torre hosting Def Jam
like with he would wear sleeveless
shirts like nobody ever dressed like
that and he was funny he was funny bro I
like that one where's that guy been I
just flew with him a couple weeks ago
where we still lives here recently you
know he has his house in st. Louis
he's got a house he's raising this kid
and guy Torry started that fat tuesdays
right that was the thing that was at the
Comedy Store
[ __ ] great guys but I Tori's it's
[ __ ] amazing there's Joe see if you
can find a picture of him write down
nothing doesn't show I think dude he was
jacked like unusually jacked for a
comedian it doesn't show him on stage
with like sleeveless shirts and [ __ ]
well the cute Martin Lawrence band that
guy was my nemesis not not in a bad
sense but in that I would have to go on
after him all the time the groom was
touring oh my god
Mitzi sure put me on after him 50 [ __ ]
times those were like some of the 50
hardest sets I ever had like doing
stand-up in the early days I would just
[ __ ] bomb just like the Hindenburg
okay just go down in flames
it's okay Jay I never really saw him at
the store oh man he was so good I caught
him but it was before your time
this was like when I first started so I
was at the store
first got passed in 94 so this was like
around 94 95 before you came along and
he was on fire
Martin Lawrence was on fire and he
people forgot how goddamn good he is
because he went crazy and he had all
those issues and you know he's wearing a
rubber suit and he had a gun he got
pulled over and he said he was
dehydrated he was on some sort of drugs
and they locked him up in a psych ward
like there's a lot of nutty [ __ ] with
him right
so people forgot how goddamn good he was
when he was in his prime but when he was
in his prime yeah there he is and bad
boys but that's not the prize that's the
standup though was what was up when I
saw him at the comedy store and you know
he would wear [ __ ] like leather
jumpsuits and [ __ ] and just rip that
place apart he was on fire and he was
another one that had a bunch of jokes
that people had decided were offensive
it's when MTV was getting upset at Dice
Clay and when they banned Dice Clay for
offensive material I believe he got
caught up in a controversy about
offensive material - it's like the early
days of political correctness they
decided to get pissed at certain jokes
the other day I was driving I was
thinking about news radio you so crazy
you [ __ ] hired not horshack but
you know Steen Epstein to play your
brother yeah Apollo I was 17 Nick
DiPaolo and Bryan Callen oh my god where
did you pull up Epstein well they hired
Epstein but Nick DiPaolo and Bryan
Callen I brought it okay I thought that
yeah hi Epstein - yeah no no no no no no
no I I didn't meet him until he was on
the set he was a real nice guy though
did he pass away yeah yeah I checked it
I'm feeling good it was really [ __ ]
sick bro your buddy the one guy you
introduced me to from that baseball show
you were on the Spanish guy and I was on
there with you nice guy Spanish guy yeah
you are the baseball show yeah well I'm
Kim's little Barney Whelan bar Mike
Starr Mike Starr whoo
the Spanish guy that came to visit at
the store a few times he's second guy
yeah I just donated to his there's a
dude from Star Trek remember that that
dude it's in Star Trek all the time
[ __ ] what is his name goddammit but
he was the older pitcher and I was the
young [ __ ] ballplayer yeah she was in
not Betty what was it Betty wait no the
other lady from what's the cast some god
dammit I remember her name
see if you can find the cast yeah but
you don't want images you want actual
text don't go to images sometimes it
pops up well see ya been Rose Marie yeah
Rose Marie Ben Greenwood Mike star keep
going scrolling left yeah Ben Greenwood
he thought Giessen start he's in a bunch
of movies now Dan Florrick he was in Law
& Order Law & Order the other way that
dunno Wentworth she was hilarious having
a bunch of [ __ ] Chris browning he was on
he's been a bunch of sons and he
recently was he like [ __ ] weird man
what year was that what years would say
it was more for that's when I had to
move to California I was miserable I was
shooting that's the first couple of I
was like 26 they're so weird you know
what man when when it first started out
it was fun and then what happened was
with with TV shows a lot of times you
have like these really funny writers and
these guys who wrote it originally we're
really good but the they had written for
married with children and the Simpsons
and the network had decided for some
reason they weren't strong enough to run
the show and that they there were only
writers they weren't like a real
showrunner so they brought in this guy
was a showrunner
he was terrible and I didn't get along
with him at all and they were actually
close to firing me or him like there was
like a real like impasse between the two
of us cuz the guys riding was [ __ ] I
was crazy back then dude I didn't give a
[ __ ] I had zero filter I never thought I
was gonna be an actor in the first place
I couldn't leave him on the set and so
they would try to get me to do stuff and
I'll be like what and they would like
give me the script like well we made
revisions to script and I would read it
goes this is [ __ ] terrible and they
would get pissed at me and people be
pissed I'm ready tell me how this is
funny
explain to me how this is funny and then
you know like executives are going you
know you're either were talking to my
agent this guy you know he's he's very
arrogant and and you know he's causing
problems on the set I'm like I'm not
causing problems in the set I go they
took the writer stuff they rewrote it
they turn it into [ __ ] you show me
show me how it's not you know and I I
was like very close to like killing my
sitcom career completely just by having
no filter but then they realized it they
read it and then they came has watched
some of the run throughs and the network
fired him but it was close he wanted me
out but I was one of the stars of the
show it was me and that Ben Greenwood
guy but and then I mean it was a it was
an ensemble show but I played the the
star player there was about a baseball
team a fucked-up baseball team and I was
the the guy was always causing trouble
and wrecking his car and going crazy and
so they were having a real problem with
me but what it was because these guys
that it originally wrote it these guys
were genius they were really really
funny and they took their words and just
butchered it and turned into some
hackneyed fucked-up sitcoms which is
what they usually do well Jim Breuer was
in the pilot with me Jim Breuer that was
made like a baby
so weird so Jim Breuer was in the pilot
with me he played the mascot for the
team [ __ ] he was funny man and Jim and I
were buddies from New York there's Jim
that's Jim Breuer now Jim Breuer played
a pioneer who he had like the the bait I
feel like like he got in a fight
Curren and Kevin Martin but back that up
or that we see the white light of the
screen yeah where you see the words like
right there Kevin Kern rather in Jeff
Martin sorry I [ __ ] her names up Kevin
Curran and Jeff Martin with the guys who
who wrote it and they were really really
nice guys and really funny guys but they
were writers you know and this was
something that they had created and then
the network just butchered it and then
it wound up getting cancelled then I was
ready to move back to New York but I
[ __ ] up but I had already got a lease
on an apartment I got an apartment on
Moorpark in Studio City or it was
actually North Hollywood and I was like
[ __ ] already got this apartment and like
what do I do and so I'm like god I got
to stay here because I got a lease and I
was like [ __ ] I want to move back to New
York I hated it out here I hated dealing
with actors I've never been around
actors and that thing that we were
talking about before where people just
like say things that they don't really
mean because they think that you're
supposed to say those things because
there's like a pattern of behavior me to
do yeah you know I thought he was
amazing in that film yeah I thought he
was excellent I thought he had a lot to
offer I mean there was a lot of that
kind of nonsense out here where I was
used to real people I mean I mean for
sure I was a flawed person I mean for
sure I was rough and I said I just I
wasn't didn't have good decorum like the
way I communicated I was a rough guy you
know I'd come from fighting and then
went writing to stand-up and this is
only a few years later I'm doing this
you know I had my last fight in 89 so
this is 94 I mean this is just a few
years after that I was still very
sketchy you know so I didn't belong I
felt like I didn't belong there I felt
like I couldn't be myself everybody was
like reading The Hollywood Reporter and
variety on sound like the [ __ ] you guys
reading this [ __ ] for I kids like this
it was just that the whole thing to me
was like this weird play that people
were putting on where everybody was
trying to pretend to be something so
that they can get auditions and I
remember going on some auditions and
dealing with some of those people
casting agents that had all this power
over you and they they exhibited it like
they exerted it when you were in the
room with them they didn't communicate
with you like you're a person and I'm a
person they communicated with you
like you want something from me I don't
know if I'm gonna give it to you hmm let
me see what you do it was just the way
they did it was just so shitty it was
just it was gross it was just there was
still this funny oh it's gross
I mean this is this is the thing that
people have the real problem that people
have with this Harvey Weinstein
situation it's not just that the fact
that he was a piece of [ __ ] to all these
women
it's his position of power that he had
over them that he exerted he got himself
into this position and then used that
position to on some I mean according to
Whitney like Whitney Cummings was
talking to me about this she's like what
you're hearing is all the women that
said no to him she's like that guy [ __ ]
[ __ ] talk about how [ __ ] economy and
it was part of the deals that he they
even they even went after one of the
girls he was [ __ ] that girl from
Donnie Brasco and she did the movie with
Gretchen Moll yeah she did rounders oh I
remember the blonde cute thing now if
you watched Donnie Brasco she's in
bounty Brasco she ain't got a [ __ ]
line in that movie not a line really not
she's an extra in that movie basically
Sonny blacks girlfriend but when you see
her in [ __ ] whatever she's got a
bunch of lines now and it was because
she was [ __ ] Howie they just went
after a couple weeks ago gretchen ma guy
who went after just you know Angelina
Jolie in the troop oh they're all saying
yes there is a dick suckers listen they
all got a suck a dick eventually yeah
she's pretty
look I had heard that there was a lot of
them that were actually very successful
that [ __ ] him I mean this was this
this guy's thing it's it's kind of it's
I mean it's [ __ ] up and it's dark but
once that gets going and once that's
what he does how do you stop that train
other than what they did if they all
know they all know and nobody open their
[ __ ] mouth so you could suck my dick
a couple of them open their mouth a
couple of them again they got swept
under the carpet and that's always gonna
happen but I rather [ __ ] you know the
rest of these like Angeline the rest of
these people
listen I'm over brother I don't want to
hear this [ __ ] no more it's it's it's
amazing like just a [ __ ] that these
people create in their worlds and you're
right when you go to these casting
things
and you see these things you see the
[ __ ] [ __ ] it pours out of a man
well it's one of the reasons why the
people in this town are so crazy it's
because they're insecure to begin with
right the only reason why anybody
becomes an actor like why people want to
be famous not the only reason but one of
the main reasons why people want to be
famous is because at some point in their
life they didn't feel valuable at some
point in their life they felt discarded
they felt abused they felt ignored and
they had this inescapable need for
attention this this hole that cannot be
filled and that was the driving force
that led them in acting where they could
be on that stage and everyone was
looking at them all eyes on them while
the microphone was on and the words were
coming out of their mouths and they were
in the play or in the movie or doing
stand-up even it's a lot of the same
stuff that propelled you and I being
ignored as a child you know like the
feeling like you were nothing and then
realizing that when you're onstage man
then you're something like that person
up there with a spotlight on them that
person is shining that's a something
person that's not me I feel like I would
but that thing that leads you to become
an act or want to become famous is also
like it's it's so [ __ ] up with acting
because you have to get chosen it's not
like music or like stand-up where you
can look at stand-up all you have to do
is you do open mic nights you get funny
you build up an act and then people come
to see you you build up a career and the
next thing you know you you become a
successful comedian that's what happened
to you that's what happened to me but
with acting you have to get chosen you
don't you don't have to work like if you
do plays nobody is ever gonna [ __ ]
see you ever you're never gonna make it
out of place nobody's going to see
famous play actors nobody gives a [ __ ]
about them you have to be in movies you
have to be in television so you have to
get chosen so you have this whole chain
of like Hugh maybe I'll pick you but I'm
not sure are you the one and so you have
to develop this sort of personality that
fits in with their what they're looking
for
you have to mold your sensibilities and
your ideas if there's a lot of pee
people that are in Hollywood that don't
have opinions of their own what they
have is a series of opinions that
they've adopted and adapted because they
think it's going to lead them to be
successful they heard at Star book you
know how many times I got an audition I
hear this like mine this is my a lot of
people don't like to audition I like to
audition can I tell you why cuz I [ __ ]
with them cuz you're funny you know I've
ripped my pants out you know if you
watch what's that show on CBS that's
been on forever
I don't watch one Monday nights Big Bang
Theory the one before that
How I Met Your Mother I did how you know
how I Met Your Mother
I didn't you know you did it yeah if you
watch the episode you're like Joey
you're an extra I'm an extra you know
why because I went into the audition I
had no underwear on and there was just
seen these things that pop out of chairs
yeah decide things the way she goes get
up to read when I when I got up to read
and this yeah the [ __ ] thing got
caught in the hole in my pants and my
dick came out all three women sat there
and I go did you see the egg roll and
then I lost him for sure they even told
me they go you got the job as I was
walking down the street on Fox my phone
rang my agent goes go back you didn't
read I didn't even read it they called
my agent said we love this guy I went
back they saw the Cuban I groped you
know well it was probably not used to
someone with confidence that didn't give
a [ __ ] you know I went to an audition
one time Broadway the guy had to I never
forget this the guy was a white-trash
guy like this family moved there there
was a pilot for ABC and this guy is one
of those guys that he had a little
circular pool in front of his house and
he was he was water his ship but at the
same time he had like a thong on he's
fat he's got jewelry and I'm like one of
those guys in Long Island I'll never
forget I get to the audition all these
guys on that Tony Lago got arrested so
all these big Italian dudes and I knew
they were gonna get the part bro
I think I'm gonna get the part I'm not
gonna get it but I had warmups on all
right I had a warm-up side with the
string and had white tighty whities and
had a zip up jacket and I had away 380
so I walked to think oh I know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna take my pants off I'm
taking my sweats off walk in and what do
you think these two ladies say to me
hold on one second we'll be back with
you in a minute so they turn around
that's my cue [ __ ] I took those
sweatpants off I took the shoes off and
my socks and I walk closer and I took my
shirt off
when they turned back around all I had
was boxer shorts on like the tiny
Whitey's that's it Ted's hangin out stop
it Hannah nobody on the way and then and
they did I suppose a to another like oh
my god
I'm like I'm not putting on [ __ ] all
right I'm breathing this [ __ ]
so you were supposed to like waves to
say good morning
all right they're like action and then I
can't even look at me cuz I'm completely
make it you know can't even look at me
and I'm making believe I'm flipping
burgers and they look over them I go
living like a doctor that's it they
booked me when I got for the audition
it's that was the Reid living like a
doctor they even gave my own line I
wanted to they gave me whatever line I
said in the audition like whatever they
said wasn't good enough I don't know my
own [ __ ] line yeah that's that's
probably why you got it look look at
Joey he's just saying that's when you
were in those big daddy shirt yeah look
how big I was Jesus Christ you were
enormous back then don't sound so must
have been like what two thousand then
right yeah this is mm mm mm when I met
you like right after my chair brought
you onto the set of Newsradio but then
they were all like um who is this guy
with leather jacket on is this guy your
friend like oh yeah that's Joey
by the way that's look at the re comes
out of your butt by the way every time
you call me that's what comes up I call
me right now
call me watch this hilarious that's us
in the pool in Austin Texas when we're
doing cap city you me and Ari we're
doing tap city and Kate was there oh
yeah that's the old days do you know how
to call yeah oh it's just please this is
why you gotta get a new phone how are
you this is why I gotta get a new phone
because there's what happened
whoo let's get out of here Joey it's
2:15 I don't want you get stuck in
traffic no I'm good I love you guys what
you got tonight yeah no I got uh I got a
[ __ ] ballet thing I got a dinner and I
got a trick the trunk what are you doing
November 1st what is November Wednesday
next Wednesday November 1st you won't do
the ice house no I'm doing a bunch
Wednesday night you doing what podcast
oh you do podcast at night move that
[ __ ] can't do over the daytime really I
always end up canceling and people
cancel on me it's do a podcast on
Tuesday or some [ __ ] I do this week I
have to do Sunday and Wednesday oh you
have to yeah I'm leaving Thursday how
about a Sunday and Tuesday
what do you mean I do the Ice House on
Wednesday we need to submit because I I
scheduled this guy for he don't really
do Wednesday
who are you doing wheeler wheeler Walker
yeah he's good bat he can move around
he's doing some type of tourist oh yeah
yes he's killing it out there then the
following week I'm only in town Monday
and Tuesday cuz I gotta leave to New
York on Wednesday for the [ __ ]
festival so I get back from Omaha Sun
damn just don't want past Monday
I love you don't forget Omaha Nebraska
next week [ __ ] and the week after
that Gotham comedy club with Dean del R
is Iran what a bunch of us the New York
Comedy Festival come on out [ __ ]
thank you for being legend where's the
beats out old here I got a pistol
[Music]